All right.
Let me sure.
I got everything
Bozo here.
Okay.
This is like a record for me to guests in a row on a Thursday podcast.
All right,
we ready?
Yeah.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
And I'm just checking in on you.
What's going on?
How are you?
How's your week going?
That's wonderful.
Wonderful.
All right,
well once again,
two weeks in a row,
we,
uh,
we have a special guest in studio.
This is the one and only comic legend rich shiner who has a new book.
He's here to plug,
um,
that I actually got a couple months ago,
but my wife was so god damn pregnant,
I've only been able to read bits and pieces of it.
I read all of,
I killed in 2006.
He's got a book called,
uh,
kicking through the ashes.
My life as a stand up in the 1980s comedy boom,
which personally is my favorite era because I watched all of it and that was,
and that made me want to be a comedian.
And all that.
So rich,
welcome.
Welcome to the podcast bill.
Um,
I got to ask,
so what year did you start officially as a comedian?
Because everybody always has their,
yeah,
yeah.
Well I did to open mikes and I went to college for a semester.
He'd always it,
they always try to delay when they stuff.
I really want to be doing it six months.
They're like fucking a 52.
So when,
when is your official?
Uh,
January [inaudible] 77.
Wow.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
Washington DC.
There were no comedy clubs.
I was going to say like,
wait,
where was there to Gig?
Yeah,
it was,
uh,
a friend of mine,
you know,
I was funny.
And he said,
you're funny.
You've got to do this.
I don't even know if we knew it would call it stand up.
He's just going to take you down.
Dude.
We can do this.
You know,
you could do it.
The comedy at this plan,
you were in law school and law school.
Okay.
And uh,
and uh,
was the ego on a coffee house?
It was just this basement in a church,
you know,
I'm just all talent nights.
Right.
And I,
and I've followed a poet.
I saw the tape because my brother,
yeah,
I have the tape and the tape.
Audio,
video,
audio,
just audio.
It's just a lie.
Always big black box cause sets like a shoe size cassette player.
Right.
Recorder and a and m and the poet is,
his last line was like the mango.
We are ripe for the revolution.
Oh God.
Right.
Gate Two late,
Huh?
Exactly.
It's way ahead on mango.
Nobody's talking mango is 77 right.
But you're right.
Wait,
bind.
The Vietnam was over way over and he was still trying to do that shit.
So when you guys went,
that was what fascinated back then because it because of you guys that there was
a comedy club,
your whole generation is the reason why there's a comedy club scene.
And I'm always like read stuff about Jay Leno and it was just like,
yeah,
you need to be like,
go down to the combat zone,
which is where I'd like the red light district,
what Boston used to be.
And you'd,
you'd go on between like strip
anywhere,
anywhere.
This Guy Howard vine who took me out the first time,
he was like my unofficial,
she says,
I found another place,
like a talent night called the gay cabaret.
And we were,
so we had,
we just don't like gay cabaret,
like the Flintstones,
this is a 77 minute classes was packed,
packed.
There was nobody out the closet except
my overpopulation pushed out,
you know?
Right.
So we could end there and it was,
you know,
it was a gay gay club and the guy was very good.
And I said,
hey fellas,
you know,
normally great soap and talent and that,
but,
uh,
this is,
this is ladies night went once a month to have a ladies man.
And again,
we're so clueless,
we don't get it.
We're like,
ladies,
like,
fantastic man.
I still don't care.
What does that mean?
It was lesbian slash items.
It was lesbian.
Oh,
I thought you meant bottoms ladies nights out.
Yeah.
Wow.
And I go up in front of this lesbian crowd.
I mean,
they,
you know,
I'm the reason they're there to hide.
Get away from guys like me.
How did it go up?
Just a swing.
Oh my God.
I mean,
you know what I mean?
Chill.
I'm chill.
Freezing cold.
I mean,
a woman told me offstage,
finally,
just,
I mean,
I got one like I did.
I was,
I did,
like my buddy told me,
he said,
you said like,
I guess I'm your worst nightmare or something and got a kind of a left.
But you know,
you have student joy.
I thought,
oh,
that's encouragement to do more instead of take that as your exit as a cue that
we,
we didn't come here for this.
Yeah,
you're done.
And the woman just walked up on stage,
took me by the arm and led me off.
Just let me,
Oh,
I've heard of that.
You know,
when I started out,
I,
I had a Gig and I,
I didn't know it was a,
I didn't know it was a gay club.
I just got a Gig.
The fucking guy didn't tell me the place was called Queen of hearts.
And what killed me was it was only a couple of towns over from,
uh,
from where I lived and,
yeah.
And that was like still,
it was the eighties,
early nineties.
I was still like totally like a,
um,
you know,
not accepted.
There was no,
let me guess.
Billy crystal played gloves,
like the only guy played a gay character and that whole thing just went away.
So when I found out I was all like,
parented,
my truck's out there,
I was all like homophobic,
come over to suck a dick.
Right?
So I,
um,
I went there and I was wearing my college,
like sweatshirt came walking in like a 23,
24 year old.
And I walked by this guy and I forget what the hell he said,
you just said like,
oh my God,
my fantasy or something like that.
And I was just like,
I was like,
wow,
that was really forward.
So I went down to the end of the bar and uh,
one of the women I was working with,
I was like,
I walked in,
she goes,
hey bill,
how you doing?
And I said,
hey,
I said,
guys,
Hey,
that guy down the end of the party,
but he's a little happy.
She goes,
why?
I got a guy and go down the on the bar.
He goes,
I go,
he's a little happy.
And she finally got,
she goes,
bill,
everybody's a little happy here.
This,
this is,
this is a gay bar.
And then I looked around,
I was like,
Oh shit.
I was totally freaked the fuck out there.
Then,
you know,
by the time I get to New York,
I was just like,
and I,
you know,
you start broaden your horizons.
You don't give a shit.
But uh,
so you started out there.
So when I,
what,
what made it blow up the way it did that all of a sudden there was just,
you could,
you know,
instead of having to go on after a poet or a stripper or whatever,
he had to do,
like,
I was always interested like,
what,
what?
Like what years did all of a sudden these scenes started,
all these independent,
like Boston had a comedy scene,
right?
The thing,
whoa.
You know those guys,
those Lenny Clarke and Barry Crimmins of these there,
there's a scene up there.
There was a scene in Washington DC.
We found this bar.
This guy started doing comedy at this bar.
So Lewis Black,
myself,
Kevin Rooney Ronson,
and all these guys showed up to start doing up as a little barn
southeast Anacostia like it was the fact that it was stand up exclusively
might've been like,
oh yeah,
oh yeah.
It became packed immediately it became like wow to me that,
and there was a,
in San Francisco with a holy city zoo and that comedy scene,
there was one in Houston and comedy workshop would Hixon Kennison and those guys
were starting out.
Now did Elliot,
cause I know Dangerfield was around since like the 60 so like New York and La
Actually,
hey look,
I was doing it for like a year or so.
And a friend of mine said,
she goes,
you know,
there are comics like you're doing this up in New York City.
I was like,
what?
She goes,
he has her comedy clubs.
So she took me up there and there were,
you know,
the Improv,
the comic strip and catch a rising star.
But I didn't know about until I went there.
That's so fast.
And because like there's no internet,
nobody knew anything.
Like this guy comes in when light comes into l Brooklyn,
it's like you don't rent.
And he walks up to me,
he goes,
hey,
I want to do uh,
some standup comedy.
Yeah,
we at the end of the show,
he like put guys on the,
no,
I'm a comic out in San Francisco.
We were doing like this out in San Francisco is like what?
She had got a place of holy city zoo.
His name was Tony Depaul and he was running a holy city.
So,
so he told me,
you're going to come out of here man.
We're doing this out there too.
And I was like,
what?
People are doing this?
You didn't think like people are doing it,
we're just doing it.
And you don't know.
Nobody was talking to as a scene in Philly,
there were about six or seven cities that had scenes percolate,
percolate.
So how did those guys back in the day,
like if they had to do way back to like Ed Sullivan,
like how did you put your set together?
I know those guys did Vegas and they did casinos.
I guess you just had to be based in New York or La to get stage time to
actually,
yeah,
but those guys,
they,
but they didn't,
there were places all over there were,
you know,
the,
the nightclubs started happening right after World War One when like supper
clubs and stuff.
They started doing the speakeasy and all when,
when prohibition came in,
so the comics moved in,
out of all the bill started moving into these nightclubs to make real money.
Right.
That's where it started.
So they're always,
you know,
back in the fifties and sixties they called them the toilets where he's guys
were trained.
You know,
they got to,
you got to work the toilets,
a little,
a little bar out in Jersey to do a little comedy,
a little show.
You'd be part of the show,
you know,
there's a singer,
a dancer,
right.
It wasn't exclusively comedy.
Look for danger fields.
Wasn't exclusively stand up,
you know,
dangerous how to singers and stand ups.
And also they were having said that the piano,
they haven't changed shit off.
Hello Ma'am.
No,
no.
So what year did,
so then I guess,
imagine as a supper club started to go away,
then your guys scene then created that Cedar Comedy Club.
That's right.
To my generation.
They weren't going out to the dinner clubs,
you know,
calling out and have a dinner and see a show.
Nobody was doing any more that was out.
You know how he's dressed up as old people stuff.
So we are in rock concert.
So then that kind of like started fading.
Right.
You know,
you're going get a little older,
you want to date,
you just can't go date,
you know,
so everybody's kind of looking for the next thing.
And it happened like some guy opens up a comedy club,
you know,
there's the three paint comedy clubs out here in the late seventies in
California.
Those.
Mitzi opened a place down in Pacific beach and 76 and moved over to s into La
Jolla 77th and there was a guy,
Mike Kelly opened up place the left stop down in Newport beach.
And then Mike Lacey,
which you've been at the comedy magic club down her most,
the beach in [inaudible] 78 they were the first three paying,
like paying.
They bring comics in from La and pay him a couple hundred bucks.
Wow.
And then Garvin's in Washington DC opened in [inaudible] 79 January [inaudible]
79 start paying comics from New York to come down and do it.
So at this point you've been doing it like two years.
I've been doing cheers and I became an emcee there.
That's why metal is comics.
I started working with Seinfeld,
Bill Maher and Overton.
And at what point did you,
did you start to sense like,
wow man,
like I sort of jumped into this thing that has just taken off.
Like what point did it really seem like,
like this?
Like the sky's the limit.
It was almost like a real estate boom.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I didn't,
you know,
it didn't until we,
well,
I mean it sucked into it.
We weren't making money.
You know that the comic strip in Fort Little loader to open like January or so
80 I remember going down there and I'm working with my first wife,
Carol Lee for Joe Pollster,
Mark Schiff and Kelly Rogers and,
and Kelly pulls me over and a comedy Condo,
right?
That the first comedy condo.
So it's clean and just kind of float.
It's gonna float inside.
Wow.
Got a boat and he goes gigs at that point.
He goes,
come here,
come here.
Any of this,
whatever this guy says you can do,
tell them you can do it.
If he asks whatever he has told you,
you can do it.
It's not going to phone guy.
He goes,
Hey,
I just opened up this club in Ottawa,
Canada.
I need a guy could go do two 45 minutes,
such can you do two separate 45 minutes show?
It's like,
Oh yeah,
Jesus Christ.
I hang up the phone.
I got Kevin,
I got like a half a half.
They buy everything.
They take everything I'm killing.
Right.
I'm killing everything.
He says don't worry,
you'll do it.
Go do it.
So I grew up there.
I do it a week.
Right.
You know that my strategy was to do all the materials you need to cause he's the
same crowd.
He didn't,
it was a big bar.
It was just a big word.
Physical comedy rooms.
At first it wasn't like they set up,
oh we're going to be,
you know,
we're open up a new club,
we're going to build this club.
They just,
there was a rock bar.
He wasn't getting a lot of business in rock bar.
I don't know where you got the idea of someone to do comedy.
Right.
So once,
twice a month he was doing comedy,
brought a comedian it.
So I'm gonna just guess what happened cause they don't really pay attention to
how long you're up there.
It's just how well you're doing.
Did you pull up short on your sets or did you do think I was counting back
there,
man.
I'm drinking shots.
I'm trying,
I'm trying to come up with Deb smoking weed between the sets,
trying to come up with new,
you know,
I'm just up there doing whatever I can do to try to,
you know what I mean?
I did all the material I could do that I had upfront and then just ran around
the room like Jerry Lewis,
you know,
like I was out of my mind.
Wow.
You know just you save a bit for the end to closing thoughts about saving that
closer opener is like just funny in a hold them just hold the stage and in the
and you pulled it off.
I pulled off so the end of the week the guy goes,
he's paying me.
He goes,
this was great man.
It was like a weekend,
you know,
like three days or something.
He said guys on the phone wants to talk to you.
I pick up the phone cause the guy goes,
I got,
I got a club in Montreal,
I heard you're great.
You want to come down here now come on over.
Just come over now.
And I did the next week of Montreal and then he puts him in the phone with,
with uh,
mark,
um,
uh,
from Yuk Yuks Breslin from Mark Breslin from [inaudible].
Same thing I want,
right.
The Breslin in Toronto.
So I went up there and I did like three weeks in a row.
Came back.
I'm a headliner.
I thought I'm a headliner.
Wow.
I didn't know what it was.
I was at two,
three years in.
I was,
yeah,
it was like in 1980.
So I'm like three years in,
but I was opened up for a lot of rock bands.
I was at at that point,
you could quit your day job.
I didn't have a day job.
My last,
my last day job was,
yeah.
About then because I was,
my last day job was working in New York City.
I was cleaning out apartments for the mob.
I didn't know that's what I was doing,
but that's what I was doing,
cleaning them out.
What happened to all down,
down,
down to X.
Got shot for return in the fucking truck.
What would you get this?
You don't remember this,
but 77 down that err,
my,
my first apartment was in a base,
wasn't in real apartment.
It,
she slept some balls thrown up every other building was abandoned.
Squatters everywhere.
Oh,
that's,
someone's had an east village bankrupt,
right?
He's bankrupt.
Dinero in taxi error.
Exactly.
So they start selling buildings for a buck.
But you had to promise to rehab the building within a year that turn it into a
rental proper homelike God.
Right.
So they're $10 so I'm not,
I could be set for you had to fix them.
Right,
right.
Got It.
Fixed them up.
So I'm having a hard time paying the rent.
The landlord goes,
hey man,
you can you do carpentry work?
And I go,
yeah,
I can do carpentry work.
He says like,
Oh,
we're gonna help these guys are,
how much of your life has been like,
yeah,
I can do anything.
They just fucking showing up and running around like Jackie Lewis.
That's amazing.
So you say,
yeah,
want won't show up.
I go over there.
These guys in New York guys,
they figured out in three seconds.
I can't really do carpentry,
but they um,
you know,
I'm an okay guy.
You know,
it gives him cigarettes and beer.
Go get some cigarettes and beer for us,
you know,
go do this,
go do that.
You know,
I would go for an form,
right.
So at the end of the day,
the guy goes,
yeah,
you can't do carpet,
but can you clean out apartment?
I go,
well yeah,
I can,
you know,
my family.
I can tell me a manual labor man.
That's,
that's how we stayed on the planet.
Manual labor.
So I show up the next morning,
there's three young Italian guys.
I didn't even know they're standing outside of building to pass around a half
point.
Oh,
they go,
hey,
you ready?
Yeah,
I'm the new guy.
yeah.
Okay,
let's go.
We weren't worth throwing squatters out.
We're cleaning out apartments.
Oh God.
We're throwing people out of apartments.
You know,
we're going in with throwing,
we're going into the shooting galleries.
Man.
People are shooting up with phone stuff out.
The windows were hustling people out.
Well Shit,
five bucks an hour break,
five bucks an hour under the table,
five bucks and throw people out on the street.
Now break down the whole emotion of that.
You walk up to the doors and unlocked.
Is it locked and you walk up the door.
And I had been in a squatter place when I first moved up there,
so I kind of understood it,
you know?
But you see it like extension cables,
running them from building a building.
They were,
you know,
there's still interest in from everywhere to back up with your life.
So how the fuck did you say you go up to,
you live in the water building?
When I first,
how does that go down?
That was,
that was 74 when I went to New York in [inaudible] 74 but I had no plan and you
had no money and then you'll see an abandoned building.
You walk,
there's other people in there.
You Guy got escape from New York,
people crawling up out of manholes.
People,
people,
they'd get a building,
they don't,
they put you see locks when outside of the door.
There were no locks,
like a key lock,
right?
I would have a padlock,
padlock.
Right.
That's how he got in and get out.
And then he'd locked inside it bolts and lock
the insight and it have electricity stealing from one building to another
building,
whatever they were running cables or someplace that had no electricity,
they would just care that it wasn't a fire hazard.
I love that there's some guy that actually could be working as an electrician,
but he's deciding to live for free in this fucking building.
If people are fascinating to me.
All right,
at night,
now you're on the other side.
Okay,
then fucking student has become the master.
Now you're going to throw someone out like yourself as you want on drugs.
But so what,
what was that?
Pos crying.
Screaming,
fighting some no.
People were like,
okay cool.
Cause they'd gotten notice.
It wasn't like surprised they did ignore it and notice it.
Put those as buildings and we bought and you've got to leave,
evacuate,
you know,
or get out whatever it is.
And they were ignoring it or they,
and so some people are cool.
Okay.
We're going.
Some people that kicked in doors,
we go running in,
we thrown her stuff out the windows,
right.
It was one where there's so many abandoned buildings and they'd be like,
all right,
fuck it.
I'll just grab my shit and just go down the street and around the corner.
I'll have another one.
Yeah.
I don't know what their attitude was.
I mean,
I didn't really care.
I mean it was pretty hectic.
It was pretty.
Did you have to physically do a couple times we had to like fight off people or
push them around,
but she hasn't guys,
these guys were rough.
They were young and rough man.
Oh,
okay.
Did they have the Joe Pesci shame suits and shit.
I watch too many movies.
They were just right where they were dressed.
They were dressed and ready for business.
The three quarter letter to the court.
A leather,
but have you jerk off like Warren?
I was knocked that guy,
man.
Wow,
that's fucking amazing.
So,
um,
I don't want to spend too much in your past because we're here to,
to,
uh,
I mean we're definitely gonna go back because I'm a geek for all of this shit.
But,
um,
let's talk about the presence here.
You're kicking through the ashes.
Let the parts that I read,
what I loved about it is you do not sugarcoat any,
like the what happened?
The odds of you making it anything.
It was really kind of like,
like you just kind of laid it out there.
Like,
how do,
um,
I know you've done books in the past and stuff and how did this whole thing
like,
I mean,
it had to be through just telling stories.
The guys like me,
no one know how interested I am in this shit.
You know,
you tell the stores for years,
you tell these stories and sometimes I hear stories come back and go,
well that's just,
that's my story.
That's not how it went.
Yeah.
You'd tell the story or whatever.
Like the Ali Jo Prater story,
I'd hear the stories were like,
uh,
the Comey had that one because I've always seen his now he's now full.
You guys listening.
He's a legendary comic from the comedy store.
I believe it had a cowboy hat and the beer.
He was right.
He was doing the Larry the cable guy,
sort of country western comic before.
And I always read his first name is oily cause um,
I have like a learning disability or I'm just a moron.
And then someone finally said the name,
I'm like,
Oh shit.
That's how you say his name.
So that guy,
Gilbert Hertzog was his real name.
Gilbert hurts hardtalk heartsong and he went by Ali Jo Prater.
Ali Jo printed,
looked like Yosemite Sam.
He's a short guy,
was heavy at cowboy boots,
a cowboy hat,
you know,
he looked like a cartoon character and he was a classic,
may see back when these clubs started popping,
the places were packed.
They didn't need guys to draw.
They had packed,
they wanted guys to sell alcohol.
We were liquor pimps,
you know,
who sold the most.
And Allie Jo would drink on stage and the crowd would drink with him.
What would they pay you guys back then to have started escalating fast and then
you first go out,
they go,
you know,
it's an 800 bucks a week and then they want you back.
We want him back when he's other clubs wanting you.
So we'll pay it twice.
Twice.
I went up by about 400 bucks 20 years later when I started.
That's what I loved in New York when we almost had that strike,
it was like,
it was 50 bucks for a weekend spot for like 2030 years,
50 bucks,
50 bucks in everything else up.
All the components were multimillionaires.
And finally we were like,
what the fuck?
And we asked for a hundred just knowing that we get like 75 and they completely
freaked out.
But uh,
anyways,
getting back to sort of escalating faster.
But,
but guys like Ali Jo word,
you know,
he was a real,
he sold you come in,
they go,
Ali Jo just sold like $13,000 worth of liquor last week.
And what was his style?
Was it?
So,
uh,
he was like
Larry the cable guy.
Foxworthy.
No,
he was blue.
He was little when he was,
and he was,
you know,
he would chug a beer.
I thought he'd started act by just like chugging a beer and going and then he
belch and you know,
that everything thing I learned in college,
oh chase us.
And so he set the tone early.
I would not want to follow that guy today.
He was,
and he,
and he would literally took anybody's act and there's an old line,
and I don't know who's lying this was,
but somebody wants,
says if Ali Jo came up and bought your beer,
I mean she just did one of your jokes and Ali Jo shared a joint with you.
He did a couple of your jokes if Ali Jo lead on Atlanta,
coke for you.
You just played Cleveland.
Yeah,
he didn't care.
And,
and I did,
it seemed like back then,
like certainly through like Vaudeville,
like people just taking other people's shit.
It was always seemed annoying,
but like it wasn't like the way it is now where it's just like,
it's like I don't post nine 11 like,
yeah,
why are you being hostile?
Like I remember seeing George Burns one time on 60 minutes or something and he
said,
you know,
yeah,
I used to do this bit,
Blah Blah,
blah,
blah blah.
You know,
he tells the joke,
he goes,
you know,
you know it's,
he goes,
dad.
I mean it's not a great joke.
I don't think melty would steal it.
And like he threw that out there on TV and years later I was just thinking like,
oh,
he's just ribbing.
And then years later when I became a comedian,
I was just like,
wow.
Like he really meant something by that.
And that guy must've been,
you know,
at least fucked with his act on some level that if he's,
that George Burns is on 60 minutes and fucking call somebody out for,
for taking his shit.
So it didn't matter to him like it does now.
She did not see the Milton owned that it used to call him the thief,
a bed gags.
He owned it.
He,
he like,
he was like,
I,
I didn't steal this from where I stole that one.
Or they didn't care like we did.
Right.
They did worry about stealing her acts back involved.
[inaudible] they used to,
the only way to like prevent it was they would pay stage hands to protect their
acts.
So if you came in and I just played there and then you came in and you start
doing my bits,
sandbag drops near you.
Oh Shit.
We like give you a warning.
You know,
they got like a heavy warning,
but then see that air
chute you could get away with before cell phone cameras and stuff.
You could literally deliberately drop it on the guy's head.
He dies and we know what happened to him.
We haven't shown up that fucking underneath the stage.
Wow.
It changed the Lenny Bruce's time.
See before that the comics were just kind of Shtick,
you know,
and so you do some stick and it,
people were buying jokes and selling jokes and they were pretty interchangeable
from California.
Boy,
my arm's tired.
It was just all shit like that.
It didn't matter.
So when learning and those guys turned to make them what the comic said was
important,
it became artful and it mattered and you became tied the material.
So like what you said mattered and people wanted to believe that that was really
you.
It was really your opinion.
That was really your life.
Then it mattered.
Then you started taking things and it mattered.
Okay,
so when you come along,
I mean that's,
that's 25 years after Lenny Bruce.
The thing that it didn't matter with you guys was because there's no youtube,
there's none of that shit and you guys had just going up after poets and
strippers and stuff.
So once I got to just go up and survive or once I fucking got in the business
and mattered,
it started manner.
But there was so few comics we could police the community ourselves.
Right.
That's the difference.
You know,
like a guy became a thief.
He doesn't get to work the clubs,
he doesn't get the work that the AA rooms.
It was like when I start,
when I started in Boston,
dude,
if,
if you,
if you went over your time,
you went over your time and by over your time,
like at,
you know,
we told you to do 25 minutes,
you did 28,
28,
like you were in the fucking dog house.
Like,
dude,
what the,
you did three extra minutes.
Like,
like it was such a huge thing.
And forget about stealing jokes.
It like,
like I'm so fortunate that I started in Boston and all those Ding Ho guys,
like,
so set the bar so high that um,
if you are any hack,
if you like to rivet,
if they'd let you go for like two,
three years,
zero k you're influenced by Gavlas Sweeney or a Nazi or something.
But then after that it was just like,
dude,
you need to come up with your own shit.
And,
but,
and it was one of those things like,
Boston's an unforgiving place.
So it's just like once you are labeled you,
if you had to leave.
So,
um,
see that's it.
That's it.
You got trained,
you got trained.
There's nobody doing that training anymore.
But you've got trained and that's how he did it involve built to the same sort
of things,
man.
They trained you,
they trained,
the guys would be coming up with,
you'd have to learn to do it the right way or you wouldn't get any time.
What was the first like real comedy club?
Like a line,
like,
you know,
going up to auto,
but like you,
you work,
you felt like,
like when did all like those a room start coming up?
Like the punchlines,
the uh,
started around [inaudible] 82,
they all started,
you know,
there's some great rooms is started,
but a lot of these tunes they started,
I mean I wrote it in a book.
There's one like you go,
you're going to have to Minneapolis to play a room.
I'm going to play a place called Mickey fins now on these rooms rejected.
Just tool them together.
So I get out there and you know,
I felt like the gunslinger coming to town,
I'm like one of the first acts they bring in.
I'm from New York.
I see all this guys.
Jeff's is Stereo Louie Anderson.
Ross standing in the back while bill bower or stand in the back.
I said that,
no,
there was a local comics there.
Those guys were all from Minneapolis,
Minnesota that are all back in room.
They're all staying.
I see.
I can see him.
You'll get him.
You go there.
They are there.
They go.
Their hair to check me out.
Right.
So I'm going to
hit that stage man.
Hold on.
No,
I'm here man.
I'm going to rub their man.
I'm going to rock star,
you know?
Right.
So I haven't checked anything out so I go running up and jump on the stage.
The stage was just a bunch of milk cartons,
right?
Real crates with a sheet of plywood on top.
God.
So I go fly.
I just surfed the whole thing.
A whole thing just takes off.
I just go flying to go to a couple of tables,
hit the wall,
partially separate my shoulder,
jump up.
Like probably the biggest laugh.
You've got that huge.
They're like,
hey,
everybody's laughing at you.
They put the stage back in place and I did my set.
Oh my God.
So who else,
who else was a part of that Minneapolis scene that was a big names to Saturday
Anderson.
Yeah.
You've been watching Louie on Zach.
He's great.
That's what I love about comedy is is there's sometimes is like,
dude,
you should do something with this person.
But who would ever would have thought that we should play Zach's dad and Zach
was a went to clown college in France and ends up in Bakersfield,
California.
I was talking to my wife about that last night.
We were laying in bed one than than the commercial came on for it and that just
like this is fucking like perfect casting together going like who to have like
night.
That's it in the way that they go back and forth.
It's like they've been working together for like 50 years.
They're like an old comedy team and that's one of the things,
one of my favorite things as like a cause I eat despite how long I've been in
this business,
I've always just,
I've maintained that whole nerd,
sorta huge fan of,
um,
of stuff like that.
So,
um,
who is a guy that when you was in the early eighties,
like,
you know,
there's always those guys that,
when you start out,
you just like,
there's no fucking way this person,
if this person doesn't make it,
nobody's going to make it like those guys and that you can be the worst manager
in a world and you knew that someone was going to make it.
Do you remember seeing anybody like that?
Well,
you knew it.
This is,
you know,
a lot of guys don't realize it,
but you knew,
look it back.
He'd go like Leno,
Jay Leno,
you,
first time I saw him,
I go,
this guy's a killer.
I've always heard that.
I heard,
he's like mean just destroyed rooms.
He had the belt for like what,
15 years before he basically for it.
He had to do the tonight show every night.
Eh,
I mean,
you know,
I'd go into clubs and I'd be like,
I'd go in,
first thing I'd say is,
who's got the record?
Who's got the time,
you know,
who's done the longest here?
Eh,
this guide Clinton Hurst it out in 45.
It's done tonight.
It's over tonight.
You know,
I'm doing too easy,
you know,
and I'd go gun and for everybody.
And then I'd go into town and after Leno started working with clubs,
right when he started doing Letterman start pop a big,
you're going to go,
who's got the Jay Leno just did three hours,
three hours.
What did you lock the doors like Wagnerian opera,
what they do and hold the audience here at now you have four ovations.
They brought him back four times.
That's,
um,
and he still had the materials.
That's what's always blown my mind about those people.
Like,
man,
that was a period where people were trying to like set the record and they'll go
on to stage for like seven,
eight,
nine hours.
I was just always pictured like eight hours in.
You just say,
Hey,
what's up with chairs?
You know,
it just like,
like how do you still have at that point it's,
it's just like you're just not getting that.
That's,
you know,
that's like world ray.
You might as well,
he's sitting on a fucking slag pull it.
That's exactly excellent.
Kills me is somebody actually sat there and watched all of them.
There's a fucking,
you know,
two people left from the wait staff that have to stay
there.
Yeah.
No this was,
but this was a legit show.
This was a legit show.
Cause people were drinking and doing coke and they had,
they,
the crowd can hang right,
will legit this four to drunk driving laws change.
This is a little different.
What class were you from as far as like,
so I know you were in New York.
How long were you in New York?
Belzer was the king in New York standup comedy back then to catch?
Yeah,
he was,
I mean,
you seem work.
That room catch,
he just owned it.
He just set the record for playing like a TV character for the longest time on a
show or something like that.
He said something and I remember being at Nick's comedy stop and the early
nineties and he was headlining and he was going,
yeah,
you know,
they want me to do this,
uh,
this procedural show or something like that.
You know,
when you think you can think it actually,
should I do it?
Should I do it?
I remember sitting in the back club going,
what the fuck is this guy asked us?
Of course you're going to do,
what should I be on TV?
Absolutely.
I didn't realize how much money he was making as a comedian,
but like,
uh,
that's kind of cool that I remember reading that like within like the last like
few weeks that he just said some fucking record for playing the same guy in the
same show since basically my entire standup career,
like almost last 25,
25 years.
It's been that long.
Yeah.
So you were a guy.
Yeah,
he was the guy,
Gilbert Godfrey,
us all when he,
you saw him,
we were like that,
that he's the guy.
I mean I wouldn't,
I once watched him too many nights in row and went down to the East River and
burned all my material burned on my notebooks.
Oh Geez.
Burned them all.
I said,
I'm just hack.
I've always told the story.
One of my favorite ones I ever saw him,
he went up at Nick's comedy stop one time in front of a bunch of fucking drunk
Boston morons and they were not getting him and he didn't waver at all.
He did his shit.
He had this little old man yellow sweater on.
And I remember one of his jokes cause all the comics were dying laughing and he
was just bombing in front of this crowd.
I remember he goes,
yeah,
I went to a party the other night and I ran into Jackie Onassis and I said,
Jackie,
do you remember where you were?
And we're all dying laughing and nobody got it.
Nobody got the joke.
And then he would just go onto the next one and do fucking dead,
like silence.
And he toughed his way through that.
But,
uh,
first time I saw him,
I wasn't in the business was I saw him in one of the,
uh,
Beverly Hills cops movie that you were in Beverly Hills cop two.
What was that like?
Uh,
you know,
it's funny,
I mean,
I think I filmed for like four days for five seconds of screen time,
a couple of hours.
And it was fun.
It was hanging out,
you know,
it was that time when I saw it.
Wow.
This is the star Eddie,
Eddie Murphy.
There was a scene where to go on.
All right,
Eddie.
Uh,
we've got a hold on man.
We got changed some lighting and he goes,
I'm ready.
He goes,
yeah,
what?
The director said,
hold on a minute and we'll get you meant so that he goes to me,
he goes,
come on,
let's go.
So he goes,
grabs it like a bag of bread off the pref table,
and we'd go down to the playboy mansion.
So we just get out and starts feeding.
The geese were just told bread to them.
So I'm about five,
10 minutes later,
one of the 80s comes.
There was Eddie there ready for you now?
And he just started to turn around and just keep seeding,
feeding them the geese.
Eddie,
we're ready.
We're ready.
He does.
He ignores him.
They leave to come back five minutes later anyway.
Are you ready now?
And he's just,
he made them wait.
They made him wait.
He made them wait.
Why should
I go?
That's power.
That's the,
you know,
he's like the fucking balls.
That guy.
I would never,
I'd be like your how high jump.
Yeah.
Hat in hand.
I'll never get a no,
I've never understood like people that,
uh,
what's,
what's funny and tragic is watching people pulling those moves when they don't
have the power,
which I've seen a lot,
especially now,
where so many aspects of the entertainment business,
because of the Internet have just gone down the shit like the entire music
business.
You know,
anybody nowadays who complains when we lose all the good music all sucks.
I always go,
well,
you get what you pay for.
I'm guilty of it too.
I I stole by Lyme wired a lot of shit.
I love color.
Yeah.
A couple of fucking laptops that this got virus stout before somebody finally
went like,
dude,
you're in this business,
you should pay for it.
Like I think it might've been Russman,
eve in New York said that to me and I haven't,
I haven't illegally downloaded a song or anything and like a dozen years way
back to like a Napster limewire was the last one that I use.
So,
um,
but anyways,
yeah,
I've,
I've seen people like,
um,
try to pull that too.
You know who I am and all of that and the people who do that now it's just like,
dude,
you are not paying attention to this business where like remember like back in
the day to try to get,
if they got like two major stars in a movie,
it was just like,
holy fuck,
this is going to be like a blockbuster.
Forget about now where like every movie is like Ocean's 11.
Like everybody got just bumped down.
Like,
like,
like the shit that I would go in and audition for in like the nineties you'll
have now a guy who like used to star and fucking movies,
like B level movies is going and taking that spot.
All these stars are on TV and you just see these people pulling their moves.
But um,
I,
I can't,
I mean that happens on a movie set.
Like it,
like the lighting isn't right.
It's a lot of waiting around.
I mean there,
there's an entire crew film crew there,
people all over.
They had,
you know,
the scene was they were going to shoot Eddie just walking past a bunch of women
playing volleyball in Bikini's.
Right,
right.
So we get up to the scene and they start doing it and the,
and the director's yelling,
it goes jump higher,
girls jump higher,
jump higher.
He's trying to get jiggle gone.
And I see,
I go to Eddie Ego,
there's too much dupont out their manager and Eddie,
cause I love you though.
Have goes what?
And he goes,
he tells me what he said,
director lady goes,
yeah,
you're right.
All right,
let's shoot the scene.
Forget it.
Oh,
it's all silicon man.
Ain't no jiggling.
It happened now.
And how has Eddie handling,
uh,
I mean,
did you know Eddie before?
Yeah,
I know him from back in New York and a day.
I mean the first time he came in the Improv I was,
I was the emcee on Sunday night.
I was like the regular,
when I was in town,
I was down in like 46 or 45th street on the west side.
It was all 44 44th and ninth.
Right.
Right there.
Yeah.
Cause I used to live in that neighborhood and we used to go down and uh,
I read this whole thing.
It might've been something I heard from you or something and now it's like it's
a pizza place or something.
And that's where Richard Pryor that it really raw video of him just standing
when he was stopped being the bill Cosby clone and he was turned into Richard.
Like he literally was turning in to Richard Pryor the greatest of all time.
And like that always blew my mind that that was within like 15 blocks of where I
lived.
And I would go in there and get the pizza.
The pizza was only okay,
but I just wanted to be like see,
like see that wall.
We're just wondering where the fucking stage was.
Yeah.
Can I ask a total key question when you walked into that,
because it's basically the same space.
Where was the stage walk in
the stage is all in the back of the room.
There was a,
there was an emergency door exit right by the stage.
And the stage is a little,
you know,
was it all one room?
There was no walls.
You didn't watch it.
There's one room,
there was a bar,
there was a,
there was a bar out there.
Everybody hung out in a bar.
It was a good bar,
a cool bar.
Everybody hung out there.
And then you'd walk through this little narrow,
narrow,
narrow hallway,
but short,
you know,
and the men's bathroom was on the right hand side of literally like a toilet and
a sink in,
in like a one of those little closets.
And then you'd walk in this little hall and the light was right there like by
the service bar.
So if you're on stage and you see Rodney come to that light,
you know,
he goes,
danger fields here,
kind of get off,
got to get the Rodney on quick,
he's making around,
it's getting ready to do it tonight show or something.
So you see people's pop up into that light area.
Probably see his fucking silhouette to,
and you know who he was?
Oh yeah.
You just see him.
He just see me just,
he popped any,
as soon as you saw him,
he'd pop out and,
you know,
get up Rodney.
I was like,
because I saw the Rodney and I was on the stage.
I'd cut mid joke,
you know,
and then that,
hey,
we've got a special guest here.
Right?
I remember Cologne.
I remember going off and Rodney coming on because,
hey,
you know how to fucking move.
The kid now has a,
and he moves,
he knows how to move.
That's okay.
Awesome man.
You know,
I liked it and it just reminded me one time I did,
uh,
I did a benefit at this theater and a beacon beacon theater.
I forget what the hell,
the goddamned benefit,
what's,
what was the sickest lineup I was ever on?
It was a,
John Stewart was hosting Max Weinberg Bard,
his band,
Tony Bennett goes on first,
then Bruce Springsteen,
then they auctioned off one of his guitars,
uh,
to this rich crowd that goes for like a hundred grand.
Then fucking Joe Mchale had to follow that.
Like I tell my accounts.
Got It.
He has to have the,
I followed fucking story.
Right.
Um,
and then I went up after him,
which,
you know,
he was the total buffer to get it back to,
all right.
Settle down your expectations.
This is what you paid for here.
Right.
And Seinfeld was closing.
That was the lineup.
And I remember when I was doing my set,
I was conscious about not being too dirty because I mean,
Seinfeld's like the king.
And I remember looking over,
I was getting close to the end of my set and he was standing on the side of the,
the,
uh,
the stage and you know,
the light was behind him.
So he was like back lit.
And I knew who he was with his silhouette,
like that's how famous this guy is and to me,
and it wasn't just Jerry hanging out,
he had the suit on,
it was Jerry ready to go to work.
And I was immediately thinking like,
oh my God,
am I too blue?
Is he going to hate me?
And My pissing them off,
am I going over?
And I remember when I got off stage he went like,
uh,
I walked by him and I was just,
I was just,
I was almost afraid to say hello.
I just like walked by an east wind.
Very funny,
very funny.
And then I apologize for working.
You know the way I do,
I said,
oh sorry of above line.
He goes high and I don't care.
Almost like laugh.
Like dude,
I don't give a shit.
And I'm thinking like,
that's right.
This guy always worked clean and he worked cleaned before there was even comedy
clubs.
So I can't imagine him going on after these guys who would chug a beer and then
burp and be like,
that's what I learned in college.
And like that sort of energy is fun,
but it whips him into like this frog frat boy frenzy and then you got to go up
there and if you have like a more of a,
you know,
just straight laced kind of like,
yeah,
I mean I have a beer every once in a while,
but guys like I'm not letting this totally affect my life,
you know.
Well first of all,
I love the fact that you did that.
That's the training.
Got in Boston and go,
I'm part of the show.
I know I'm not closing someone to respect the headliner.
Oh,
you know how it works.
that was another,
that was another way that you would get,
you would get blackballed.
I remember,
uh,
there was a comedian up there,
a Mike Donovan.
You ever worked with them?
I know who he is.
Fucking hilarious guy.
And he used to always say this thing was hilarious and it'd be like,
it'd be like,
yeah,
just go out there,
uh,
you know,
do like 20 minutes.
Say No.
Keep it like,
you know,
three of five fucks is,
what do you say it is?
The thing,
he wasn't bullshitting.
He was like,
people in Boston counted the fucks.
So I remember,
uh,
you know,
sometimes going over it and being in a panic like,
oh my God,
that was my sixth fuck Donovan's going to call Mike Clark and I'm going to be,
I'm going to be ruined in this town.
I said fuck six times.
So,
um,
I mean I don't want to sit there and be like the old guys and just cause I don't
know what it is like for kids coming up now in mind.
It's the kids to me now or anyone up to like 32,
33,
um,
coming up now.
But I'm sure that they have their,
uh,
their whole way
that all it always change it.
But I liked that.
But you know,
Seinfeld always had that discipline.
I remember working with him and then he's Jersey gigs.
Jersey gigs were like $55.
Jersey gave this started.
There was like the first paying gigs we could get go out to Jersey and some bar.
Right.
And so,
you know,
it's survival time in a bar.
It's a lot of guys would be like,
what do I gotta do to get by,
you know,
fuck with a Crown Shit Dick Jokes.
What have I got to do to get by?
Right.
And I remember working with Jerry on time and he goes on and he'd follow that
and he stays right to what he's doing.
Man Works Clean.
Brings him to him.
No,
but he wasn't killing it does not like at all.
They don't came to him.
They were like,
oh wait,
wait.
The party's over it.
It wasn't great.
But he never broke.
He never wavered.
And afterwards I go,
wow man.
He goes,
he goes,
I'm getting ready to do it tonight shows.
That's what I'm preparing it though.
He had the folks had the Longreach focus.
He was like,
I'm practicing this material here now cause I'm going to do to some of the
tonight show.
Right.
I'm working this out now.
I'm not worried about my $55 Jersey Gates.
Well he's one of those guys,
a long range view.
He's one of those guys that he just fucking knew where he,
he that's,
he just knew where he was going and he just a,
you'll
never meet a guy that doesn't suffer fools the way he does.
I still want to get around them.
I get nervous.
I'm like,
I'm going to say one stupid thing and this guy's going to,
I'm going to get that look and that's just going to be,
you'll try the local lake the same way.
Like his act is the way he lives his life.
There's no fat,
there's no extra words or any of that type of shit.
And then the guy just fucking,
just like,
he just walks towards what he wants,
walks right through it.
I mean,
not,
not like in a malicious way,
just like he just,
I on the fucking prize,
that guy you'll get back in the day guys would go like,
you know,
and I'm like,
is that because you don't really know who he is up there?
Go,
Oh,
you fucking paying attention.
You know?
Exactly.
You know what pissed this guy off the missing sock and a fucking dryer.
That's who he is.
Man,
I just paid attention.
He's fucking paying attention to the details.
That's what's irritating.
This guy,
I did his web series one time and I told him that.
I told them I hate it,
that they said his show is a show about nothing.
It's like,
no it isn't.
This guy has contempt for 90% of people and activities.
I was actually nervous saying it to him and he laughed and he goes,
I think you're being generous by saying that you know that it's only 9.9% yeah.
But it's uh,
um,
that's so fucking cool.
So when did like,
uh,
Oh God,
there's so many things I want to ask you this as far as,
so the Improv,
the Improv started in New York City and then they opened the La one,
right?
Cause they open the la one because he realized everything was moving out to la.
When Johnny moved,
when Carson moved,
that was that when he moved to the 72,
the whole thing shifted.
The axis shifted,
right.
Everybody had to go out to La and the comedy store just opened then.
So comedy store became people going on the tonight show going,
yeah,
I work out at the comedy store in La.
That became the place.
Wow.
Right.
So,
but he's like,
I got to get out there.
And then the,
cause he wasn't getting the brand recognition and no,
he was getting at when he's in New York and the comics would go on the tonight
show in New York and go,
I work out at the Improv here in New York,
like Klein or those comics.
But then it shifted,
immediately shifted.
That's why Leno went right out to la.
I know Saul,
Freddie Prinze go on the tonight show and say,
I'm working at the comedy store and Leno goes,
I got to get out to the comedy store.
Right.
And so the franchise didn't start opening until the eighties like 84 when Mark
Anderson opened one in San Diego.
Then that started,
he started opening up those men that franchise did bud light,
bud franchised it out.
When he saw the whole boom happened,
that's when he made money.
That's when he really made money.
Mark Anderson Open these clubs and bud was making huge,
it's like the Trump thing.
I've heard a lot of that stuff that says Trump on it.
They're paying for the name for the name.
That's so smart.
So bud was getting like a gross of every club.
I think I got to answer because like I,
you know,
you're doing the tonight show with Johnny Carson,
which has to be the most nerve wracking.
Huge possible thing.
Like sleepless nights and like,
yeah.
What,
what,
what year did you,
did you first do 84 you did an ATF.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
So you're going to go on there.
I mean it's just at that point it's,
it's w that show,
like I,
I feel bad for young people.
They don't understand how huge that fucking show was.
It was just like,
it was,
it was everything.
Everyone's was the Beatles on the Ed Sullivan.
It was our standup comic.
It was everything.
So you,
they tell you you're getting the show,
so you must be like over the moon excited.
And then for me,
what would immediately hit would be the dread of like,
Oh fuck,
now I have to do this and I have to somehow compartmentalize the fucking terror
of this guy who can either invite me over,
gave me the old K or all of my peers are going to see that he didn't like me
because I watch that shit.
So everybody watched it.
Yeah.
So here's a deal,
how it worked,
and correct me if I'm wrong here,
he would give you,
what would he give you?
The,
okay,
he didn't call you either call you all,
but that was the highest.
That's it.
Oh,
you got the,
okay,
so he's still coming back,
which is accepted for the first time.
You'll know.
But then there was the one where he would just be like,
they'll do drumming his pencil on the table.
Oh,
you take his pencil and just drumming it and not looking at you.
And that was like it,
man.
That was the worst.
And he knew he was,
he knew what he was doing to the comic cut that day.
I read it.
I read that book that his lawyer read.
I mean how ice cold his mother was like the ability to do that.
It's like that's the trickle down effect.
Um,
I'll tell you how I dealt with doing Letterman because Letterman was my Carson.
Like I literally had to,
I was so fucking like thinking what am I gonna do?
I had to like work up like a healthy level of hatred cause that's just how I'm
wired.
I'd be like,
yeah,
fuck this guy for making me so fucking them name is a great guy.
Came over,
shook my hand and everything.
But like I had to literally be thinking,
fuck this guy and then to go out there.
So I went out there and I had,
thank God I had a great set and I remember like you see it on TV and you think
he's fucking 80 yards this way and the band's a hundred yards.
They're all right there.
Like you could take two steps over and shake Paul's hands,
another three.
You could shake days.
And I remember doing my set hearing Dave laugh and it was such a fucking,
it was more relief.
It's like,
oh my God,
he's laughing.
And he's the last one that was,
you know,
your and get married.
So it was like in the wheelhouse cause he wasn't married or anything like that
is,
it was just,
I don't,
I just remember thinking like I was so fucking relieved when it was over.
Matt.
I was just so relieved.
So tell me what that was it but it sorta a Letterman show,
let her room's always behind you on camera.
So the orange could,
you were let him go.
It was in the sight line.
So they're looking at UNC and let them run over your shoulder.
So if you'd have let them and laugh and you could die.
Oh Wow.
You know,
so by the time I,
it,
they didn't have like,
he was,
he was already over at cvs.
I'm talking about the NBC show.
Okay.
So anyway,
84 I was in New York because,
uh,
I left the summer Olympics were out here and I've said,
I'm going to get out of La,
this,
it's going to be a mess.
And so Kennison and I booked over to New York for the summer and I was there and
I was working out and Jim Mccauley,
the tonight show,
booker saw me in New York and said,
said,
you're ready man.
Want to do it in two weeks.
It was all just so you know,
did you cobble this block?
People don't understand.
It's
a very unnatural set back then.
I don't know how to do it down.
Maybe they just pull five minutes out of the rack and tack on five.
But you pull like a greatest hits thing.
You pull a joke from this bit,
you pull and you cobbled together with,
he's weird.
Segways right.
You know,
you do a skiing waterskiing joke,
then you go,
you know when you come out and water,
your hair's messed up.
You know when I get my haircut and it was like torture.
Oh,
it's horrible.
Yeah.
And uh,
so I,
I put this set together,
you know,
that he helped me with and then I'm practicing it every night.
You know,
just going into clubs every night.
Then many times I could run out to Jersey Gig,
coming back to him,
a bunch of monitoring it while you're brushing your teeth,
the whole fucking thing.
Completely freaking out.
And I was drinking and doing a lot of blow back then.
So I was like,
I got to quit.
I've got to quit.
So week before I thought I'd just,
I'm not going to drink and do drugs.
You high when they told you you got the Gig?
Oh yeah.
We went out to a bar afterwards.
Mccullough and I went out to a bar when he says,
you got it,
let's go talk about it.
We went out to a bar drinking.
I didn't do blow in front of him cause I didn't know whether he did it or not.
I wasn't going to risk that,
you know,
but we were drinking.
Yeah.
Hell yeah.
And uh,
I got so stressed out,
I got shingles,
I broke out in shingles.
Oh my God.
You know,
by my,
my ass and my leg would just blistered up and I didn't know what,
there wasn't,
went to the doctor.
He said you got shingles,
man.
Yeah,
you got shingles.
That's an old man's thing.
What do you,
what are you stressed out about something?
Yeah.
Let me see.
Yeah,
I'm doing it tonight.
Shit.
Then he'd probably be like,
wait,
what is it?
Oh yeah,
you answer the stress because now I know you're watching and you're going to be
at home going like,
and it's funny,
I got shit.
He got blisters on his ass.
Wow.
Yeah.
And so you're standing backstage,
right?
So this is Burbank,
obviously before the shooting of Burbank.
So there's,
the fucking curtain was iconic and that fucking gold and blue and weird ass,
all those weird colors.
All I could think about was fucking up.
I mean,
literally,
I'm like going,
I can't fuck up.
You don't think about how much fun you're going to have.
I didn't think like,
oh,
I'm going to it.
This is going to be fun,
man.
I earned this.
I deserve this.
I'm going to go out and go in and have a good time and say,
what's up Johnny?
You're not just like,
yeah,
yeah.
Did you have the panic thought of what if I,
what if I forget where I am?
What if I forget what I'm saying?
Cause at that then that did not happen to somebody say happened to me or my HBO
special.
I blanked on my HBO special.
Oh God.
For how long?
When I had to stop taping,
I just want,
I,
I'm lost.
I'm lost because it was getting,
it was now instead of a five minutes unnatural to cobble together a half hour
out of like hours and material and posted that,
you know,
like just all together,
just kind of just cut and paste,
cut and paste.
And I was practicing that for a long time and I got out there and I just went,
what am I doing?
What the,
you know,
it was like one of those things where you're going,
what the fuck am I doing?
It was almost like biff from death of a salesman.
What am I going to ask?
Contemptuous bid here.
What happens is you go out there and rather than just doing a show,
you know you're being watched and then you start watching yourself and then you
leave yourself and then you're sitting in the crowd going,
why is he moving his arm like that?
Cause you're literally thinking,
oh I'll do,
we've all fucking bed.
Yeah.
So when you're standing behind that curtain and you just,
and just,
if adrenaline was unbelievable,
it was unbelievable.
Then you walk out and then you hit it.
And as soon as,
but it's like every other time,
I mean my literally my mind went blank like every time before I go on stage,
my mind goes blank.
I if you go,
what jokingly?
What joke?
I don't have any jokes.
I can't remember anything.
Yeah,
totally blank.
Right.
And walk out there,
dude.
At first joke,
get the first laugh and go.
Yeah,
you're locked in that first laugh and you're locked in.
So you went out,
you did your first joke.
Yeah.
How did it do?
Good laugh.
You got to go to the land and you know when you're doing it,
you're plan it.
Everybody says the first joke is just them seeing you and hearing you for the
first time.
So don't expect the big laugh so you don't put your,
you know,
I was just told the three jokes in,
that's your first killer joke,
right?
You know,
three jokes in that should be your first kill joke.
That's how you kind of planned it.
I know all these fucking guys with their ideas and then the fifth joke,
she'd be this more shit to think about it.
So natural.
It's on that now.
So it was unnatural.
You go out there and you end up,
you end up having had this,
I would really good set and have a really good set set.
You'll now you're like,
how long did it feel to look over at Johnny?
Like fuck,
oh no,
I'm going to lock eyes with this God that looked over big smile,
you know,
big smile and a circle finger like you said,
like big.
Okay.
And I go,
oh can I came backstage and Jim Mccauley greets me.
I got a beer,
hands me a beer.
I was great.
Fantastic man.
To stand over here.
Stand over here at the end of the show.
You staying here and when Carson walks back,
the way he walks back a re after every show,
this route he takes backstage,
you're going right there on the route.
He stopped,
shakes your hand.
That was great.
Get a photo op.
Fantastic.
You going to come back soon?
You can come back.
So yeah,
I've got a picture.
You know you had a picture and you're just standing there going,
okay.
And then he was fantastic and moves on,
right?
And you're like,
this is it.
Then you go back and the Improv that night and on Melrose in West,
uh,
you know,
West Hollywood,
right?
Everybody was there.
They turn the TV up.
Everybody in the bar standing there.
You're standing there.
That's what kills me about how they redid that and I didn't get the bar
upstairs.
It's like all,
all that history,
you guys,
all those people had stood there watching their friends tonight show set.
Everybody who leaned on that fucking bar kills me.
At least they didn't.
They didn't demolish.
And John and John used to say the same thing when a new comic,
I'm glad you're in a good mood tonight because we've got a new comic coming on,
right.
And the comics would mouth it and,
and some would actually say it out loud with Johnny.
That's how much everybody knew that.
Wow.
That that routine.
Right,
right.
And you just stand there and it's like,
Yay.
And I already saw how much bloated you do that night when you're going to
fucking pass that Jesus Christ.
I had coke in my pocket when I walked out on the set that day.
That's how much I knew.
I was like,
when you watch Ron,
like fucking a Ron Burgundy and all those fucking movies that,
that look more like a documentary to you then rather than a comedy.
It's like,
yeah,
we did all that.
I had a suit like that.
I wore that on the tonight show.
I had blow in my pocket.
Yeah.
Wow,
man.
That's fucking amazing.
Well,
we got a,
I got to run back to the stomach in the middle of editing this fucking cartoon
that's never going to end.
Dude.
I gotta tell you,
man like this
you've been wanting,
I've,
I've had great guests,
but this was just so fucking,
I would,
I hope people listening as much fun as I did.
Like I could ask you a Zillion,
how do you not talk to a guy who fucking had coke in his pocket when he does the
fucking tonight show?
You're like,
I'm doing this either way.
This is either gonna make me super happy or make me want to fucking kill myself.
So his book is called kicking through the ashes.
My life was a standup in the 1980s comedy boom.
Um,
where can people get this Amazon and amazon.com,
amazon.com and we'll do book soup,
uh,
assigning a book signing at book soup over on January six,
January six,
seven o'clock,
January 6th,
and we'll do a Sania tell some stories.
Well,
you have any coke in your pocket.
I walk in,
I'll have a slow seal field would sugar.
I said,
rich,
it's been such a pleasure,
man.
Thank you so much for calling this.
My son's angry.
He can't beat it again.
He's a huge fan.
Oh Geez.
That's awesome.
He is 17 years old.
He is a banger man.
And he'd so dig you.
And he was like,
Oh dad,
man,
can I get out of school?
Can I just,
Nah,
can't do it when he's of age can come out to the clubs.
Three shout and uh,
hopefully I'm still funny at that point.
I switched shiner,
but thank you so much for coming on,
man.
All right,
All right.
Is a little bit of advertising for your over there.
Um,
all right.
Loot crate gimme the Lou.
Be The envy of your friends and get your 100% exclusive crate at [inaudible] dot
com slash burr and enter my code name Burr to save $3 off on any new
subscription.
Wait until I tell you about December's crate.
It will have you fight in the power man.
Luke crate offers an epic range of pop culture items for less than 20 bucks a
month.
If you're more of a fanatical Fashionista than try loot where monthly wearables
and accessories with cult classics and your favorite franchise.
If you want to get fancy and get a bigger box,
uh,
with even bigger loot,
there's loot crate dx.
Want to geek out your pet,
try loot pets.
They got everything.
They got all of that shit.
Get ready for December's rebellious theme revolution.
Uh,
they've designed a system to keep you down,
man.
And their meddlesome hello friends is time for a revolution.
December.
December's crepe features exclusive items from assassin's creed,
Mr. Robot,
firefly or monthly tee shirt and pin and more including an exclusive Funko pop
your dad's garage band.
Funko pop.
Do not wait.
You have until the 19th at 9:00 PM Pacific.
Just subscribed for December's crate.
When it's over,
it's over.
No more.
No more crates.
Go to loot crate.com/burn and to my code bur bur to save $3 off on any new
subscription today.
All right,
lift everyone you know about Lyft Rye.
It's the epic gets you ride minutes on demand 24 seven for less than the cost of
a cab.
Uh,
if you tried Lyft,
um,
you know what I mean?
What with lifts,
you just download the APP request to driver and they show up in three and a half
minutes.
On average.
That's really fast,
man.
Every Lyft driver is fully vetted through the 10 points safety standard,
including criminal and DMV background checks.
You know,
you'll get around quickly and safely.
Lift drivers are rated after every dried,
so only the best stick around.
You don't have to worry about getting into a filthy car was some creepy dude
with Lyft.
You can tip in the APP,
which is obviously leads to a happier drivers.
I mean,
nine out of 10 live riders,
uh,
rides get an perfect 5% rate from their passengers.
It's just a better all around experience.
Bigger isn't always better.
Lift isn't the biggest ride sharing app,
but it's the fastest growing and highest rated one.
I'm talking quality over quantity.
Thanks to lift.
You got an easy way to avoid drunk driving.
You never have to bum a ride and you never have to worry about about parking.
A lot of people are actually getting rid of their cars.
Is that true in relying on Lyft to get around down there?
Just talking shit here and you know what?
I don't,
evidently,
I don't blame them.
According to the coffee right now,
Lyft is offering listeners a special deal.
Get three rides up to $10 each.
That's a,
that's a $30 value.
If you can't do basic math when you enter the Promo code bill bird,
just download the free Lyft app today and enter the Promo Code Bill Byrd and the
payment section.
You'll start with three free rides,
up to $10 each.
That's a $30 value.
That's Promo Code Bill Burr.
Enter Promo Code Bill Burr.
All right.
SEATGEEK everybody.
Oh,
the geeks with the seats.
Buying tickets online for sports and concerts has been a confusing process for a
long time.
Yeah,
you get ripped off.
It's not confusing.
There's no confusion there.
It's like,
why the fuck does this cost so much of my,
this far away from the goddamned action?
It's always been hard to find the best deal for the game that you want or the
show you want to go to and none of them.
None of these older tickets sites wanting to change that,
but seek geek is different.
They've come along with an created an amazing APP and website that makes it
easier than ever for fans to buy and sell tickets.
Everything about Siki cause is designed to make life easier for sports and music
fans seek does all the price comparisons for you by searching multiple tickets
sites and ensuring that you get the best possible deal.
Seek does all the work and you save time and money.
Best of all,
my listeners get $20 off,
$20 rebate off their first seed cake purchase to get your $20 rebate on tickets,
download the SeatGeek APP,
go to the settings tab,
oh Jesus and click add a promo code.
Enter Promo Code [inaudible] [inaudible] we'll send you a $20 $20 after you've
made your first ticket purchase,
download the seat Geek App and enter the Promo Code bird today.
If you,
one of these fucking reads is over a minute,
let's try to blow through this one hair,
right?
Simply safe.
Ever find yourself almost all the way to work or maybe you're out with family
and friends and you get that nagging feeling that I closed that door.
Why am I married to this person?
Did I lock that door?
You just don't have to.
You just don't know if you drive yourself nuts.
Uh,
thinking about that shit.
Well you don't have to worry about that shit anymore cause you got simply safe
home security.
It's a nice extra layer of protection to know.
Simply safe is there.
Simply safe has an arsenal of sensors to protect your entire home and keep your
family safe.
Uh,
simply safe.
They just keep saying the fucking name here.
Got Rid of everything that makes most home security.
Such a pain.
There's no long term contracts,
no hidden fees.
They won't gouge you.
It's just 1499 a month.
That's three times less than what other companies charge.
And you're some big nose.
Simply safe.
Just released this brand new high definition,
security cameras.
This camera is different.
It connects to your security system.
Had sent your smart phone a video.
The second something happens.
Hey,
look at that asshole fucking breaking into my house,
jerking off of my account.
She can see everything that's going on is you're reading.
You're fucking sue flight,
so you won't have to wonder anymore.
Oh,
that's why my house is going to be trashed when I get home.
Check out simply safe's new camera today.
Just go to simply safe bird.com right now.
That's simply safe bar.com hey,
simply safe bird.com
I was riding on the Mayflower and I bought some land for captain a Rep.
Ah,
have you on the stand who came running to the deck?
Said Boys,
forget the whale.
What going on?
We Sang de d top sailors do and the fire waiver and Z.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Was Bad.
Got to keep
playing patty cake with some mistletoe and a sleigh.
Santa Claus has an itchy beard and big black boots sit in his lab.
I don't know why.
I can't say merry Christmas.
Somewhere along the line.
It became offensive even though I don't mean anything bad by
some Mexican came up to you and said,
happy Cinco de my,
what'd you say?
Dude?
What the fuck and fuck.
It's all just April to me.
Doo Doo,
Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo
friends.
It's that time of year again.
Ooh,
Ooh.
When the fuck did you know saying merry Christmas.
Become offensive,
blah,
buy,
buy.
You know,
I don't understand that shit.
Just cause I say it that,
you know,
it's like if somebody Jewish said Happy Hanukkah to me,
I,
you know,
I wouldn't be like,
you know what the fuck dude,
blah blah blah blah blah,
blah,
blah.
You know what the fuck?
I don't understand that.
I like to say merry Christmas makes me feel good.
Makes you feel good.
Right?
My chest.
A little warm feeling just like the Grinch,
you know when his little heart kind of broke out of that little box.
Doo Doo,
Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo.
This is a little a holiday break down is a,
as I as I kick knowledge about the holidays,
um,
whatever.
So have yourselves a merry little Christmas.
He is,
I don't hate Muslims or Jews.
When I say merry Christmas.
So whatever group he's walking around saying it's offensive,
go fuck yourself.
Then you'll fucking con.
Even if you're male,
you have a con because you've ruined part of my holiday.
I would never do that to you.
All right,
that's enough.
Jesus Christ.
Sorry.
You know.
Anyways,
how are you?
I know I'm tone deaf,
but you know,
I told you I was going to brace the holidays this year and I was at the airport
coming back from a Vancouver listen to this week that I had.
First of all,
this is the Monday morning podcast.
Usually if I'm going to sing badly,
I only do it for a couple of seconds spot.
Uh,
you know,
I don't know.
I just saw can,
I kind of felt it.
Um,
and I was just in Canada and they say merry Christmas up there,
which makes me feel good because you know what,
that's what I say.
You know,
do I have to go to Canada now?
They listened to somebody say merry Christmas.
I don't know what the fuck are these?
How big are these groups?
I think you just need like literally 18 people and they just,
you know,
they just hold up signs and they talk,
Oh,
what the fuck?
What the fuck?
And the way they frame it on the news,
they make it look like it's a zillion people.
You know?
I,
you know,
I don't know.
It's weird.
I'm trying to think if I ever said Merry Christmas to the,
to a friend of mine who's Jewish and he ever got offended.
I don't think they ever did
so want,
so what?
18 Una t me of friends get offended by the shit.
And then you get to call yourselves a group and then you get to start walking
around telling people what's offensive and what isn't it?
These are the holidays.
You can't,
unless you're fucking open your hearts to another religion.
All right.
So anyways,
um,
listen to this fucking week that I had.
All right,
you want to talk about busy cause my brain is going to be all over the place.
I'm already telling you that.
All right?
And I might even sing another holiday fucking song if I feel like,
um,
a pill.
Nobody's saying he can,
you know,
I don't understand the hostility.
Why don't you relax,
okay.
You just got back from the airport.
You haven't showered,
you know,
he should have taken a little bit of time,
showered,
you know,
treated yourself and gotten yourself in a mindset where you could relax a little
more and do a happier podcast.
But you didn't,
you ordered a grilled cheese sandwiches,
some chicken noodle soup and you fucking went right in wearing the clothes that
you've been sitting in since last night at the Canuck game and now you're laying
on your bed.
That's disgusting.
Um,
anyways,
this is my week.
See what I did.
I just talk myself down.
Fight more calmer tone.
You like this.
This is the new me.
This isn't the new me.
This is the guy I'm trying to be.
This is the person I think I was before a bunch of fucked up shit happened to me
and became me.
This make me become like a screaming maniac that I am.
So I'm trying to get back in touch to me.
Circa 1972,
um,
anyways,
this is my week.
Monday
I saw,
uh,
I flew back from New York City after a wonderful engagement at Caroline's comedy
club.
And,
uh,
I landed,
I had a sandwich and then me and three of my friends all went down to the La
Forum.
We saw ACDC that was Monday,
you know,
most people would call it a fucking week right there and be like,
wow,
I just saw one of the most legendary rock bands of all time.
Brian Johnson's voice sounded unbelievable.
He looked like he was having the time of his life.
Angus was still jumping around and I'm sick of people on this tour going and
you,
you know,
anger,
see,
you know,
he's great,
but you know,
he kinda,
he's Kinda lost a step.
It's like,
dude,
so have you.
I don't understand how people feel like,
you know,
they look at famous people like they're not supposed to age.
You know,
and you know,
if,
if people fucking videotaped you taking out your trash seven years ago,
the last time ACDC was on tour,
I bet you don't have such a big spring and you'll fucking step either.
Stop making fun of Angus,
the guy jumping around at 53 years of age.
Never missing a nope.
Try doing that at 16.
Tried doing the shit that he does.
I dare you to try that on your fucking you little playstation game,
Guitar Hero.
You think you could do that for an hour and a half and then do a strip tease and
moon the crowd and then come right back in.
Jump off a fucking drum riser and be right on the fucking one.
I don't think you could do that.
Leave Angus alone.
They were the shit.
That was my Monday.
Right?
And then,
um,
Tuesday I began three straight,
12 hour days shooting my pilot for comedy central,
which could not have gone better.
I think a,
we got a lot of fucking hilarious stuff.
Um,
I'm in a very smart move.
I pulled the Seinfeld,
I learned a lot from Jerry Seinfeld,
you know,
he,
uh,
you know,
what did he do when time I watched him and accept that accept an Emmy for his
show and he said something to the effect of,
Hi,
I'm Jerry Seinfeld and I am a bad actor,
but I've proven if you surround yourself with enough talent,
youtube and,
but did it,
whatever.
So I went out and tried to find the funniest fucking people I could.
So hopefully if I suck,
the people around me are okay.
So that was my Monday,
Tuesday,
Wednesday we wrapped at about 9:00 PM Thursday,
smoked a fucking stokey as men do.
And then I got my little Prius reeking of Dutch masters and uh,
went home and the next day I boarded a fucking Air Canada flight to Calgary
and proceeded Friday,
Saturday,
Sunday I went to a Calgary flame game,
then an Edmonton Oilers game and then a Vancouver Canucks game.
I always wanted to go up there and uh,
I got to tell you,
it was pretty fucking amazing and I'm pretty God damn cold.
Do you remember that shit when you were a kid?
Wherever the hell you lived.
Like I might not,
my nose has not stuck together when inhaling,
since I went collecting on my paper route and like the fifth grade,
um,
Calgary,
I don't know what the fuck is in Calgary.
Okay,
let me do my little review of the western part of Canada.
All right.
Calgary first stop.
Um,
I dunno,
I can't tell.
I don't know what the fuck the deal was.
I didn't see a skyline.
It was snowing.
Like I haven't seen it snow one years.
And then I got on their little fucking trolley,
which was really confusing and I went in the wrong way like seven times,
but the Saddledome was the shit and I sat next to some guy from Canada who said
a after everything,
you know,
like that's strange brew Shit.
Like,
oh,
they've got to get it out a a means everything up there.
It means you know,
it means like,
you know what I'm saying?
It means,
what did you say it means?
Huh?
I guess that also means what he's,
I don't know.
It's like seven.
It's like Donnie Brasco when he fucking explained out,
forget about it.
That's what a is in fucking Alberta.
They've got to get it out a and they all sound like they almost sound like
they're fucking Irish.
I don't,
I'm talking about,
but the game was great.
There was a shootout at the end of the game,
a and a panthers won that one and then I,
the next fucking day I drove up to Edmonton through towns like the towns out
there.
When I was looking at the weather map,
it was like a,
you know,
fucking red deer,
yellow knife,
you know all those Indian names.
The classic White Guy Thing,
you know,
you murder a bunch of people,
you commit genocide and then you name towns after him,
you know,
did we destroy the won the fucking punk pug people,
let's name a street after him,
maybe even a golf course.
I think that that's only the right thing to do.
Considering none of them exist anymore.
Let's do something here to remember these people after we've massacred them,
can put small pockets on their fucking,
their sleeping bags.
Did Indians have sleeping bags?
I don't think they did.
What did they use for sleeping bags that they sleep in the fucking end trails of
an animal like Luke Skywalker.
This podcast went off the rails about fucking two minutes ago because I got in
my head going did,
I just calmed myself down like five minutes ago and then all of a sudden I
stopped being funny.
I mean it's,
podcasts started off great.
I Sang Christmas carols,
you know what I mean?
I defended saying Merry Christmas,
you know,
and then all of a sudden I was like,
wait a minute,
I'm coming off angry.
Let's take it down a little bit.
And then all of a sudden I felt like I was doing the traffic.
You know,
I like the traffic down in the south when you listen to it because they,
they,
they still say a,
when there's an accident they call it a wreck.
And that always makes me feel like I'm watching Nascar.
We've got a lick down there.
They don't talk like that.
But that's all I hear at that point when someone says live,
you got to Rick,
there was a car all tore up on the side of the fucking road.
Um,
and anyways,
then when I drove up,
yeah I was going to stop off in red deer to get something to eat,
to eat just on my way up to Edmonton,
just to say I fucking did it.
And then I was like,
you know what,
red deer sounds like it reminds me of one of those,
those a and e murder mystery that I watched where these two hunters had gone up
to some fucking place to go hunting.
They stopped off in a bar,
they exchanged words with people,
they got killed and then somebody in the bar fed their bodies to pigs.
And it was one of the most creepiest fucking stories I've ever seen.
You know,
just that whole fucking feed and a person to pigs and they all look like they
were in like Creedence Clearwater revival.
So it was really fucking with my head.
And,
um,
I don't know,
red deer just sounded like that kind of shit can happen.
So I bypassed it and I continued on up to Edmonton.
I'm going to tell this story in real time.
Let's fly forward.
Okay.
I had a great time.
Edmonson was an awesome game coming up there and seeing all the championship
banners in the fucking retired jerseys had Gretzky and Aa and all you gotta do
it.
Okay.
Not to mention both the Saddledome and Northlands coliseum are just basically,
uh,
I dunno if they're like no frills.
They made an ice rink and they put seats around it and that's it.
There's no law.
No,
that's shit.
You know what I mean?
Although,
you know what category definitely had the horse skating around on the ice in
between and um,
Oh god,
why don't I get to questions?
I just bored the shit out of myself,
but there was such a fucking good time.
I had an awesome time up there.
You know what it is?
I just,
I woke up at fucking eight in the morning and I just got on a plane and I had to
come back.
And do the podcast,
so I'm skipping over a bunch of good details.
You know what did I see up there?
I saw some guy in like minus 90 million degrees Celsius,
whatever the fuck is.
I think that's like five degrees American and he was fixing a four wheeler with
no hat on
and no gloves.
You standing out that dream about Arthur funds are rarely used to dress.
When they gave him a garage,
when they ran out of shit to do with this character,
it was before he became a teacher.
But after him just hanging out at Arnold's,
when they will finally like,
okay,
this guy's like 30 he needs a job.
You know what I mean?
How does he afford to live in that attic?
He was dressed like that and it was fucking cold out and he was fixing a four
wheeler and I was,
it was.
I actually videotaped it and if I knew how to upload it,
I put it on there.
But anyways,
this is my podcast when it gets to the questions here,
people send me questions all this week.
I think I shot my load with that fucking song right up the front.
You know?
And if I stuck the rest of the way up,
you gotta admit three minutes of Christmas,
Carolyn.
Isn't that my defending my podcast?
I mean,
this is ridiculous.
Like I'm bombing is a comedian.
Go.
Come on man.
No,
and that was a funny joke.
So it was funny.
You know,
I mean a,
Hey,
this guy,
you know,
and a nice set up.
I didn't have any extra words.
I disguise the punchline.
It took a left at the last second.
Can't help it if you guys don't want to go along for the ride.
All right,
question number one.
Um,
Bill,
since you're,
you're a struggling actor trying to make it,
have you ever thought about doing gay porn?
You know,
you guys are really been assholes lightly,
but you know what?
I'm going to build a fucking be a man about a hearing.
Kay.
Let's go.
Since you're a struggling actor trying to make it,
have you ever thought about doing gay porn to make ends meet?
You already have the iconic shaved head and like hockey.
Do you have a shaved head and you like hockey,
you're gay.
Okay.
Speaking of hockey,
Sean Avery is underrated.
Anyone who calls a woman a con and then tells her that he wouldn't even,
I can't read your fucking typing.
He wouldn't come in her face because she's too old.
Is Cool with me.
All right,
let's get back to your first question.
As a struggling,
we have ever thought about doing gay porn,
obviously.
No.
Um,
what is the worst thing I have considered doing?
I considered doing commercials back when commercials weren't funny.
Remember back in the day like 10,
12 years,
10,
12 years ago,
they started to get funny,
but it was that awkward middle ground where,
you know,
you could be in a really funny commercial or you could just be like a budding
into a sandwich.
And then given that look to the camera,
light boil boy was that tasty.
You know,
I remember back in the day like,
I refuse to do a commercial because I listened to that Bill Hicks rant about
that.
And um,
then after awhile I was like,
why am I making a difficult business even harder?
You know,
granted,
I don't go out for commercial auditions,
but it's not because I'm against doing commercials.
I just don't do commercial additions because I'm lazy.
Plus they're all the way out in Santa Monica and I'm not driving all the way
over there to fucking act like I'm eating a of fruit loops.
I'm not doing that.
You know,
I do have a little pride.
All right,
question number two,
Bill.
Hey,
I'm a big fan of the podcast.
I listened to most of them traveling over the Thanksgiving break.
I did notice that you have a few favorite words and since I lead a sad,
pathetic life,
I thought it would be funny to count them during last week's podcast.
So here we go.
Okay.
Evidently this is the list of my favorite words and how many times I say them a
cunt.
Three times.
Wow.
That's pretty low.
We are in a recession.
Um,
I don't know.
I said 27 times shit.
I said 42 times.
Fuck,
I said 127 times.
Wow.
2027 times.
Let's do the math there.
That's about three times a minute.
Four times a minute to do about a half hour podcast.
Wow.
I'm the Wayne Gretzky of the f word.
All right.
Choke out a pheasant.
I say one time.
I said one time.
Okay.
You're Popeye Popeye like up,
up,
up.
Chuckle to yourself nine times.
Okay.
I don't know if that was interesting to anybody.
I was kind of interesting to me that somebody that fucking lonely.
Um,
all right.
Underrated.
Overrated.
Brendan Frasier.
Oh,
underrated.
Brendan Frazier.
Eric Lindros.
When he first came into the league,
completely bald.
Vagina and college are overrated.
I would go with you.
They had the ball.
Vagina is just fucking creepy.
It's really fucking creepy.
Um,
yeah.
Not a fan.
No.
I don't want to go down to a thatched hut either seen,
I don't do this shit.
I'm like,
I'm not taking it in this direction.
God dammit.
Um,
all right.
Three bill.
If you could have one superpower,
what would it be?
Also,
how would you use it?
Uh,
would you fight crime,
which you commit crimes or would you just use it to beat the shit out of people
who heckled you?
Um,
you know what I would do,
I would use it to a freak people out who had power.
You know,
like if I was like,
I mean,
I can't just have one super power.
I got to have a couple.
Like if I put it this way,
if I was like superman,
I could fly.
I could,
I could see through,
you know,
walls and I was bulletproof.
I would,
yeah,
I would fuck with people who had power.
I'd fly into the Oval Office,
you know,
right in the middle of them talking about shit,
or just be standing outside the window,
you know,
just staring.
And I'm like Michael Myers and like Halloween,
I would just do that.
I would just freak the fuck out.
Um,
I wouldn't use it to fight crime.
I would use it to get to my gigs a little quicker rather than flying southwest.
And I would just wear my superhero outfit the whole week,
you know,
like Steve Martin,
he always wore that white suit.
I would just wear whatever my superhero fucking suit was and I just slide in my
gigs.
And then I fly home,
no security,
no fucking bags.
I'd have little toothbrush in my utility belt.
What would I do with my,
I don't know what I would do with it.
I would fuck with corporations and,
and leaders of the world.
Um,
and all my information would be shit that I read on Youtube and Wikipedia and a,
yeah,
that's what I would do.
Um,
wow.
No fucking energy this week.
What is wrong with me?
Oh,
so excited about this podcast and I just really feel like this is a bill burr
woefully miscast and the Monday morning podcast.
I'm number six.
Bill.
I was wondering if there are any situations that you steer away from when you
work?
Audiences.
I'm not talking about something as profound as a racial observation,
but any social subjects that crowd's really don't respond to or is everything up
for grabs as,
okay.
These,
these are two things.
I don't really do sex,
sex material.
I just feel like the crowd absolutely loses their mind.
If you talk about sex,
no matter what you're saying.
And I got to Mit,
I was still a little crude when I'm talking about it.
You know,
even that's why he kind of broke off the whole bald,
the Jina thing.
It's just gets,
it's no class,
you know?
I don't know.
It's just crude.
Unless you have a really unique fucking story to tell.
You know,
I'm not like a prude or anything,
but a lot of times like when I go to see movies and you know,
two actors or having a love scene and there's some guys sucking on the girls
titties,
it's,
it's ridiculous to me.
I always look at the person like that,
that's not even necessary to moving the story along.
You know,
back in the day they would just show the cup of gold in the room and they would
close the door and then they would just play that saxophone because the always
back in the day always meant someone was going to some book.
People were fucking,
that's what the saxophone meant.
Either meant that or someone was going to do a strip tease and he had to play
with that really fucking blue.
Wow.
Fucking sound.
And everybody knew that somebody was getting some Dick.
Right.
But you didn't have to show it.
You know?
That was my whole thing with like Brokeback mountain.
I don't love mine watching a movie about a couple of gay cowboys,
but I don't know how much,
a couple of dudes fucking a tent,
you know?
I don't understand that.
And then like what?
That makes me more comfortable with my sexuality because I look at that,
I got to admit half the time there's two things that really grossed me out and
movies.
It's like over the top,
kissing his fucking gross to me and act.
People who eat during scenes.
I don't know if he's,
I have probably talked about,
this is my number one pet peeve in a movie.
Like I've gone out for lunch with people and they're eating and they talk and
they take their moments when to do it.
Something about actors,
the second they're in a movie and they start eating,
they start overacting eating,
you know,
and they start fucking point.
And with bread,
yeah,
you got fucking dude.
When they got shit hanging out of their mouth,
it's like,
dude,
why don't you finish what you're eating,
collect your fucking thoughts,
swallow,
and then present your line.
Okay.
I don't need you.
You fucking,
sorry.
I don't even,
what the fuck I'm talking about now?
There's two subjects.
Okay.
So sex and,
um,
I don't make fun of the mentally handicapped.
I just don't,
it just crosses the line.
I've done it before in the opiate Anthony Show I've piled on.
I've definitely said some shit on stage if it just pops into my head.
But generally speaking,
I don't write bits.
I just don't,
you know,
half of it.
Cause I think,
you know,
that's just brutal to me.
And then secondly,
I haven't had any kids yet and I really feel like I'm jinxing myself.
A long time ago I did do comic view and I did do a bit about movies,
about the mentally handicapped.
I don't know if he can find that on Youtube and,
uh,
my parents saw it and they weren't happy and I'm still looking for approval.
So I took that.
Uh,
I don't know.
There's too many details.
I,
yeah,
those are the two subjects.
I really don't,
I don't do shit like that.
And I also try not to do a stuff that will reinforce more chronic thought,
you know,
as far as like,
uh,
racial shit.
I try not to do that.
But everything else,
yeah,
I don't care.
Other than that,
I really enjoy pissing people off and the crowd,
you know,
um,
like whatever,
whatever group I was denied bag,
if that merry Christmas group,
you know,
the people who find that offensive where at my show,
like,
you know,
it would just basically be your duty as a comedian to just make their night as
miserable as fucking possible.
So I'm definitely an asshole.
But yeah,
those were the sex,
sex and the retarded right there.
There you go.
Those are,
those are the lines all right now.
But hey bill,
do you fish?
Uh,
no I don't.
Occasionally I have,
I've gone fishing,
but now I don't own a rod or a real,
um,
my favorite part of it is going on on the boat and hoping to see what I like
looking at wildlife.
I don't like killing it.
You know,
even if that fish are just fucking bothers me,
like,
you know,
there's already dead fish in the supermarket one and just eat that.
But then I read all the survival stuff like I should know how to do this.
But then you go out deep sea fishing and they fucking do everything for you.
You just sit down there like annual rod and reel,
sir.
They just hand it to you.
They tell you what to do.
They know where to go,
where the fish are.
And it's like,
you know,
you feel like,
I feel like,
you know when you're like five years old and your dad lets you sit in his lap
and steer the fucking car and you're like,
damn girl in the car.
No you're not.
No,
you're not.
You're a fucking child.
Um,
and I also really enjoy the drinking.
Uh,
that's the part of the fishing that I liked.
Even though booze and boats don't miss mix according to the posters.
All right,
Bill,
who do you think are the top three electrical guard took guitarists that are
currently performing?
I have no fucking idea.
I'm 40 years old.
I should know that.
All right.
My favorites of all time or Stevie Ray Vaughan and recently really got back into
Jimmy page.
I really got back into his shit and um,
I don't know who the third one is.
Take your pick,
but it's definitely,
I don't like the Steve Vai,
Joe Satriani kind of guys,
those guys who can play really fast,
but it sounds like they're playing on a Casio keyboard.
Um,
I'm not into really fast guys.
I'm into those guys.
You know those,
you know those guys,
guys that give you chills.
Speaking of which,
the best part of that is what I want it to,
the best part of the fucking hockey trip that I took was when I went to
Vancouver and they sang Oh Canada and the guy comes out and he sings the first
verse or whatever and then he stops and then he just sorta conducts the crowd as
they sang the second half.
I got literally goosebumps listening to the people up in Vancouver singing o
Canada cause I never heard it sung like that.
You know,
people in America at the hockey game sing o Canada,
the way they sing the fucking national American national anthem in Canada.
There's no passion.
You don't give a fuck.
You know,
you should have heard him singing.
And they were like,
ah,
say can you say blah,
blah blah.
And then they get to this song and they just like,
Oh God,
oh they fucking,
you know,
milking every note there,
intuit Gloria sent free.
All right,
enough thing here.
bill number nine at Caroline's to Caroline show,
you mentioned that your grandmother is 101 years old at her age.
Does she still have any messed up out of date reasonings?
My grandfather is 86 he's typical old Italian man Sharpe for his age,
but recently in an interracial couple moved next door to him and we had to stop
him from going to city hall because he wanted to have his property taxes lower
due to the fact as he put it,
a colored woman is living next door.
I swear to God.
That's true.
No bullshit.
What do you think?
Fucked up fucking classic or a little both.
Um,
that's a hard one.
Obviously if somebody you know,
below the age of 60 thinks something like that.
Yeah,
that's fucked up.
But um,
I mean the guy's fucking let's,
let's do the math every,
he's 86 years old.
All right,
let's,
why don't we do this here?
He's six plus four is 94 years from now.
It was 2012 so he was born in 1922.
All right.
The Guy Born in 19 fucking 22.
Uh,
alright.
He's 18 and 1940.
They didn't even let black people in the fucking army.
And when they did,
they put them in a special unit.
It's like fucking 15 years before
when the fuck was civil rights.
Now it was like 25 fucking years after that.
23.
Yeah,
no,
I mean that's kind of,
yeah,
that's his wheelhouse.
You know what I mean?
The same way.
I don't know like what best guitarists are that are playing today.
Cause now I'm 40.
I'm off like you just,
you're,
you're awake.
You shoved off to see,
I got my fucking 10 albums in my head.
Then I'm going to listen to for the rest of my life,
the same way old people still listen to in the mood that it had dead,
dead,
dead.
They fucking love that song.
I hate that song drives me nuts.
It makes me want to kill somebody.
But when I'm 80,
I'll still be listening to back in black and I think you take how you think
along with you.
So,
um,
I dunno.
And at that point he's 86.
Is He really going to start a hate group?
You know,
it's kind of funny.
Racism becomes funny.
Only when you're so fucking old you couldn't do anything about it,
you know?
Then he'd just become this crazy old guy who's just saying a bunch of shit.
So I guess,
yeah,
it is.
That is funny.
But you know,
it's weird isn't getting back to them.
What that kid was asking me about what you talk about right now.
I feel like I have a social responsibility because I'm talking to 14 people over
the goddamn phone to now say that that's fucked up.
Okay.
You know what,
in public on television of the guide did that that's definitely fucked up.
But sitting in your living room and your grandparents said something fucking
racist.
It's hilarious.
You know,
not cause you can donate just because they're so uncensored and they don't give
a fuck and a,
yeah,
I probably would have laughed.
I would have left.
I'm not saying I'm condoning it on any level.
All right.
Question of a 10.
Uh,
no.
What's really,
really overrated,
overrated or underrated.
Um,
this assumption that all gay men are funny.
You know what,
that's just hilarious right there.
Cause you really do picture,
I'm like that.
I've actually said that defense of gay people,
like I don't understand why people have such a problem with them.
You know,
they're fucking hilarious and exactly.
I don't want to watch two from fucking a 10th,
you know,
I have my,
but this guy says basically I work in a restaurant and we never share a gay guys
that have a great sense of humor.
But just because you're gay doesn't mean describing what you'd let Clive Owen
duty to you in great detail is funny.
Yeah,
that's kind of nasty.
I've known a couple of gay guys would get a little over the top with the fucking
description of this sexual shit that they want to do,
you know?
Yeah.
It does get creepy,
you know,
but you know what it is?
That's Karma for straight guys because how that makes you feel as a straight
guy.
That's how women feel when you,
when you know,
some girl walks by and you're like,
yeah,
I'd love to fucking been here to or you know,
whatever.
Fucking Evil Shit you say.
So.
Um,
yeah.
Wow.
That's a lot of awful images in my head.
All right,
let's get to the next one.
Overrated cable TV,
especially the movie channels because they just rerun all the same suck ass
movies like kindergarten,
kindergarten,
cop are under siege.
They still run van Damme movies and the worst are the cheesy pornos.
Um,
yeah.
You know what?
I've got to admit,
the only reason why I watch a fucking movie TV is just to watch the fights.
And I watched that show.
Dexter,
is anybody even still listening to this podcast?
I'm so fucking jet lag right now from flying to scene three hockey games,
the three nights I think.
I feel like I'm just a,
I'm reading like the fucking stock report.
All right.
Underrated.
Oh,
this dude wake you up.
The sex swing.
The sex swing is underrated.
Really?
I didn't know people were out there going fucking blows.
Or maybe you're saying it's underrated because no one really talks about it and,
okay,
let's hear the review.
The sex swing.
Really,
I'm not trying to be scandalous or anything.
Um,
if this is something people have not yet tried,
for Christ's sake,
try it.
I promise.
It makes it fun and easy to fuck.
Yes.
Because the rest of us find it tedious
and not fun.
You know what?
That's the way you should,
you know what?
I think that that's the sex swing should be for old people who get Viagra and
they still want to fuck.
All right.
Oh Wow.
I just said I wasn't gonna do sex material,
but you really just fucking,
you know,
he's fucking lobbed it over.
Okay.
This is what you do.
You fucking lube up grandma.
All right.
Not Grandma your wife now.
It's really disgusting.
All right.
You fucking take a little Fiat Agra
and then you just push her away.
Like it just wouldn't you like a little kid.
You just push away,
just keeps coming to you.
Ah,
and then you just push her away again.
Oh,
I you fucking bag away.
And when else,
what if he impregnated,
you know,
Sherry,
you'd be dead by the time the kids fucking in kindergarten,
but you now you're fucking be on good day America.
They think of that act like it was cute.
Like when Tony Randall had a kid at 72 oh that Tony and Tony fucking Randall,
you don't even if you have a kid at 72 you know,
especially if it's a boy,
what you basically just had is a future felon.
All right?
Because the fucking confusion of having a 72 year old gay man as your dad who
dies when you're in the fourth grade,
you know,
at the very least,
you know you're going to rob a convenience store.
I don't know.
I was just,
that was really,
I thought it was a,
it was an asshole move on his part and I've never been able to enjoy the odd
couple the way I used to.
Um,
all right.
All right.
Overrated.
I like this one.
This is a great one song.
This is overrated songs for causes.
You know those hacky collaboration's with a bunch of stars in the same studio.
Um,
you're a singer lead the life and death shit to someone else.
All right.
That's sort of a two part thing there.
I hate songs for causes.
Um,
I didn't mind that we are the world kind of Shit just because that actually
seemed like a,
there was so many people involved that no one really got the credit.
But like,
um,
you know,
when all those rednecks we're making those,
let's go to war song songs and protect the boys.
Those songs were really,
really fucking cheesy.
Oh,
is that Warren and Uncle Sam's going to put a boot in your ass or whatever the
fuck that one of them is.
Just really one of the most ignorant songs I think I've ever heard.
And,
uh,
and plus,
you know,
like,
who the fuck is not going to like a song that says,
you know,
support the troops and let's go fuck up some people.
Um,
I guess they've always done that,
right?
The boogie Boogie Woogie bugle boy.
Remember that about the need the data,
data,
data that bad.
All right.
Um,
and you said you're a singer lead the life and death shit to someone else.
I disagree with that.
I don't think just because you're in the public eye,
therefore you shouldn't talk about who you vote for or you shouldn't have
opinions.
All right?
Be honest with yourself.
All right,
the f this,
every bar you walk into,
there's people talking politics.
They're talking life and death shit.
People sitting there going,
dude,
you know,
we should know.
You know,
we should do right some fucking more on down the end of the bar.
You listen to him,
you'll actually fucking wait until he's finished.
You'll never call him a moron,
but then all of a sudden you have a fucking hit song and you,
you,
you don't want to hear somebody talking about it.
You know what it is.
This is what it is.
I should've just said,
this is what it is.
Rather than go,
you know what it is.
All right.
I'm like,
you could actually respond to me.
It's the fact,
it's very hard to do stuff like that without coming off as preachy.
And,
um,
that's another thing in my act that I try to never do.
I never use the word we because I saw a comedian do at one time and it annoyed
the shit on me.
He was like,
do we do this now we want a country where we bah blah,
blah.
I,
it was like,
dude,
I want to fucking choke you.
Um,
with the Mike Court.
Oh God.
Just the references are just on flying out.
You know,
this really is a train wreck.
This is like a,
what was that?
What was that fucking album that,
that dude that not from the beach boys never put up.
What was it called?
A fucking not pet sounds it fun.
They finally just put it out when he was just going nuts.
This is my podcast version of this.
Um,
saw,
oh,
that let George Michael one where he was just like,
I'm not going to be in the videos darling.
I'm just going to put other people in them.
I want the music to stand on itself.
And then his career just takes a fucking nosedive.
It's like,
listen,
okay.
Even gay or Tom Cruise,
if you're not,
if you're not fucking wear it,
shaking your ass in the TV with your little fucking stupid little scruff going.
Nobody gives a fuck.
You know?
I know I didn't give a fuck as much.
I was like,
if I couldn't see George Michael's ass,
he would.
That was a very confusing artists for me cause I really liked how he sang on
some songs.
I'm like,
when he redid that Elton John Song,
he fucking destroyed it.
But he was just so fucking a feminine.
It just made me uncomfortable.
You know,
if he just said,
listen,
I'm gay,
and I just got done blowing somebody and I'd really love to do it again,
that would destroy the tension.
And he's like,
okay,
he's out in the open.
Then he can laugh about it.
You know,
he did.
I just blow somebody and I was singing a song.
I'm what a guy,
but it's a fact that,
that he doesn't bring it up and I was singing.
Then occasionally,
you know,
he does a little fucking twinkle toes move.
It just makes it fucking uncomfortable and very hard to enjoy the music.
All right.
Another thing that is underrated,
a good waiter and or bartender,
um,
just some guys really good at his job,
especially when you don't have to ask them for anything and he's right on top of
it.
Absolutely.
Like the fucking waiters in the bartenders over at Smith and Wollensky you ever
want to go there and have a fucking professional waiter?
Slash.
Bartender?
I told you guys I was over there.
Lazarus is fucking great.
You felt like it got to him.
It felt like you're really in the rat pack.
Everybody was dressed nice.
I'm get married.
Let people know you're not a homo.
Um,
thanksgiving,
uh,
is overrated.
A day involved with nothing but gorging yourself and watching high school in pro
football,
junk food.
Brusk breakfast cereals,
overrated.
I Dunno about you,
but a bowl of fruity pebbles or co cookie crisp is just as good when you first
wake up as when your shit faced.
You know what,
I got to agree with you,
but I would definitely go with fruity pebbles,
cookie crisp and captain crunch.
You know,
as much as I liked him as a kid,
Jeff,
we get a mouthful of those things and that when you bite down,
there's like three of them.
One of them,
just one of them turned sideways on your tongue and it misses your teeth and it
hits the roof of your mouth.
I mean,
dude,
that is a fucking pain.
Like,
I mean in Guantanamo they should do that.
They should fucking put truck and Coco Crisp on fucking people's tongues and
make them bite down.
You get all the information you want.
I don't like those series.
I don't like cereals that you know or they get on the outside of your teeth and
they go right up in between.
You know that that skin that covers your teeth,
whatever.
That's the,
I guess that's called your face.
Yeah.
Gets,
gets underneath that.
You know.
And just fucking drives it in there.
And then that night you forget that you did it,
then you're brushing your teeth and of course the toothbrush goes off your teeth
and goes right into that raw fucking place.
I don't like those series fruity pebbles.
I like,
what else do I like?
You know,
fruity pebbles is one of the few ones.
I don't get that fucking crazy with breakfast series.
I liked,
I like classics.
Cheerio's raisin bran,
grape nuts flakes.
I like grape nuts,
you know?
And I know you think it will keep those things to so granulated.
They can't cut.
Cut Up your fucking mouth.
I would.
I really have to end this podcast.
I could apologize you guys.
Just one of the worst podcasts I've had.
I've just,
you know,
probably nine times during this podcast have literally just kind of come to
feeling like I passed out for three minutes and I know I continue talking so I
apologize for any Florida and sort of,
I can't even talk with me.
I said any FordF instead of any sort of,
all right,
here we go.
Let's get,
let's,
let's wrap this up bill and get on with it.
Okay.
Um,
another thing,
overrated.
A dude who has the balls to wear for that is fucking hilarious.
All right,
here's a story.
I saw a guy the other day wearing a full length raccoon coat and it looks so
fucking bad ass.
And the best part was that he also had the fox head scarf to go with it.
Maybe you want to get one of my own.
You know what?
That's fucking hilarious.
There's not enough people out there address like fur trappers,
you know,
that's also,
because that's,
that's one of those things like merry Christmas now it's just become taboo to
wear for,
which,
you know,
I wouldn't wear for,
but uh,
you know,
I would never,
spray ketchup at somebody who was wearing,
if I all of a sudden pheasant,
I almost set a pheasant.
That really is my default animal,
isn't it?
God dammit.
You know what?
Whoever wrote that in,
you got me.
You got one of my ticks.
We were playing poker.
You'd know exactly what my hand was.
Um,
all right.
One more overrated,
underrated Sidney Crosby of the Pittsburgh Penguins.
And Am is overrated.
His hyper B and the next one in hockey.
I'm so fucking sick and tired of hearing this out,
be it,
it's died down in the past year.
Hearing that he's the next Gretske I'm sick of hearing that he's next.
The next Greski he's not,
uh,
yeah.
Well,
I mean that's Kinda like,
that's not his fault dude.
That's because everyone wants someone to be the next Gretzky.
You know,
he's not writing the articles.
That's like after Michael Jordan retired,
there was a nice,
you know,
there's always going to be done hangover and saying someone's going to be the
next fucking uh,
Jordan because you want to see it and a,
it ain't gonna happen.
Um,
and I think a,
that's it.
Some quick ones.
Underrated.
Overrated,
underrated.
Vinyl.
Overrated.
The compact disc.
Um,
I think contact this or underrated,
you know,
all you people going out,
they just get your music digitally and then what happens?
You fucking Ipod dies and you lose your entire collection.
I've talked about this.
You want the comp having a compact.
This is like having the gold behind your paper money.
All right?
You need to back up your digital shit cause it's not worth anything.
Compact discs are tangible.
You have the vinyl,
definitely underrated.
It definitely gets hot and sticky and the sun.
But if you spill something,
it's very easy to clean.
And uh,
that's it.
That's still,
yeah.
Monday morning podcast for this week.
I really apologize for being so fucking jet lag.
I hope I can get some sort of points for getting right off the Goddamn plane and
um,
you know,
to when the product count,
Jesus Christ.
Listen to me.
Just family.
I'm like a fucking old woman.
Um,
all right,
here we,
here we go.
What do I have to hype here?
I'm literally taking off my hooded sweatshirt.
That's how right in the door.
I was when I fucking doing this podcast.
Um,
I am going to be,
I'm going to be a,
let me get on the fucking website here.
If you're still hanging in here,
I really should send you some sort of a gift.
Uh,
would you like to hear another holiday song?
And it's like fucking a,
I don't know the words,
you know,
you don't mind mother fucking holiday song I hate the most is silver bells.
It's just the sum of about the tempo of that song just sucks the life out of the
lower half of my body and I just have to,
you know what?
It always comes on when I'm in a mall and I really just don't want to shop
anymore and it just comes on sale.
Vrbo.
So Vrbo,
that one and I don't like a Jingle Bell Rock.
I hate any sort of jazzing up getting down to eagle,
Vail,
jingle bell rock pile,
jingle bell time.
Yeah,
I fucking hate that song.
And I hate that Michael Jackson,
Jackson Santa Claus is coming to town.
I hate the way he phrases it and I know we'll make it fun.
Have a fucking seven year old and I should just be happy that he was able to go
into the studio and perform that day.
But I
shut the fuck.
Just shut up Michael,
the seven year old.
You please just shut the fuck up.
I hate that song.
I really hate that song.
Um,
I like the classic slower once the bing Crosby ones.
Does anybody care?
All right,
I'm on to my website.
I woulda got here.
All right.
I'm in January.
I'm taking a break until January.
I write uh,
fuck,
uh,
January 8th.
I'm already back out on the road.
Wait,
what's today?
The 15th is 60 more days.
16 all right.
They get three weeks off the fucking my bitch and above.
Can we see these people out there churning butter?
I right Ahmad going to be at the Improv in Tampa,
Florida.
January 8th,
ninth and 10th.
And I haven't been there in a long fucking time and uh,
that they'd scare the shit out of me because I'm,
Florida is a,
it's a crazy animal man.
I don't know what to do with it.
I don't know how to sell tickets and Florida around.
I've gone down there.
I've done what I can fucking do.
And all right.
Now people around the country,
like why speaking in that Redneck fucking southern voice,
you talking about Florida,
Florida is and part of the south.
Yes it is.
If you get out of Miami,
that entire,
that entire state is,
is,
you know,
you could film
400 seasons of cops,
dog,
the bounty hunter.
And if you have a really,
you know,
look at Dexter.
Dexter is his fucking taped down there,
right?
Isn't it Miami vice splitting.
My told me that.
What did,
what did they have on those t shirts down there?
Florida.
Uh,
what do they call it?
A cool place for shady people.
Something like that.
Hot Place for shady people.
It's one of those play on words.
I'm not good at that shit.
All right.
I'm going to be at the Improv Tampa in Tampa on a January 8th,
ninth and 10th and uh Oh and January 8th is the show your tits show.
Just to let you know.
Uh,
that's something new that has nothing to do with me.
You know,
I'm actually against it.
I don't want girls to show me their titties during my show,
you know,
but,
it's something that the Improv's or coming up with,
you know,
I think it's sexist,
but you know,
I didn't want to cause any statics.
So,
you know,
just know that when you're showing me your tits during that show,
that,
uh,
you know,
there wasn't my call.
Uh,
I don't condone it,
but I was powerless to stop it.
So,
you know,
yeah.
I guess I'll go along with it.
I'll sign some titties after the show,
you know,
show me a phone.
I mean,
whatever it means.
I'm just there for the art,
you know?
Okay.
Uh,
and then after that I'm going to be a Improv and Houston,
Texas.
January 22nd,
23rd and 24th.
I really excited to go back to that one because,
um,
I'm actually going to hit this guitar store out there called a southpaw guitars.
They have nothing but lefthanded guitars there.
And I'm going to go there and spend some money,
motherfucker.
Um,
after that,
and we at the Wilbur Theater in Boston and the comedy connection and chickopee
Massachusetts February 6th to the seventh,
and that is at wow,
47 minute podcast.
That's how fucking jet lag that was.
I knew I just fell asleep for like 10 minutes in the middle of that.
I apologize.
This is way too fucking long.
Everybody have a merry Christmas.
Okay.
I mean that in a nice way.
Heaven.
Merry Christmas.
Even if you're not fucking celebrating Christmas,
have a fucking merry Christmas.
Got Debit.
It's not a bad thing.
It's unreal.
It's on fucking real.
How did that become bad?
I don't know.
Bill,
why don't you fucking analyze it for another 47 minutes.
All right,
I'm out of here.
Um,
God bless all.
Yeah,
I'll talk to you next Monday.
Have a great [inaudible].
Okay.
Take it easy
down the street.
Crazy ass
busted.
I don't even ask me how I went to get some help.
I walk by and Guernsey cow good.
Directed me down to the Bowery.
Slums web people carrying signs around saying,
Ban the bums.
I realize right away
when I realized
I went to your restaurants looking father told him I was the editor of a famous,
said the waitress,
he was handsome.
He wore a powder Blue Cape,
some Suzette as in,
could you please make that great?
Justin Lowe,
kitchen IX floated from boiling fat,
was trying
to be nosy,
but when and do a bank to get some real fairy rab and all the boys back in the
tank.
They asked me for collateral,
pull down my pants.
They threw me in the alley.
This girl from France who invited me to her house.
I went,
but you have friend who my boots and I was honest,
read again
house with a US flag upon display.
I said,
can you help me out?
I got some friends down in the way the man says,
and get out of here.
I said,
you know,
they refuse Jesus tea and he said,
you're not him.
Break your bones.
I ain't your pop.
I decided to have him arrested and I went looking for,
well ran outside and I hopped inside cab.
I went up the other door.
This Englishman said,
Fab,
as he saw me leave a hot dog stand in a cheery it fuck the cross from a
building,
advertising brotherhood all ran right through the front door,
but it was just a funeral planner and the mass.
I repeated that my friends were all in jail with a sigh.
They gave me his card.
He said,
call me if they died.
I shook his hand and said goodbye and ran up to the street when a bowling ball
came down the road and knock me off my feet.
The pay phone was ringing,
just about blew my mind when I picked it up and said,
hello,
if foot game do the line.
By this time I was fed up.
I tried to make a stab at bringing back some help from my friends and captain,
a rep.
I decided to flip a coin.
Either heads or tails would let me know if I should go back to the ship back to
jail.
So sailor suit my got God crying the slip it came up,
tails sales are made it back in and ship.
Well,
God back into the parking ticket off the mask.
I was ripping it to shreds when it's coast guard Baldwin as Mima name,
and I said,
Captain Kid,
they believe me,
but they wanted to know what exactly that I said for the pope of the roof was
employed.
They let me go right away or,
well,
the last I heard of a rabbi,
he was stuck on a whale that was married to the deputy sheriff of the jail.
But the funniest thing was when I was leaving the bay as SMAD three ships
sailing,
and they're all coming my way.
I asked the captain what his name was and how come he didn't drive a truck.
Lisa's name was Columbus.
God is sick.
Good luck.